SENATE ON RULES TO ORDER AND
WELCOME TO EVERYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED OUR FIRST
MEETING AS A RULES COMMITTEE IN
THIS HEARING ROOM- THIS IS OUR-
ST BUILDING AGAIN FOR
CLARIFICATION ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. LET ME THANK EVERYONE
FOR THEIR PATIENCE AS WE GOT
UNDER WAY TODAY. AS WE CONTINUE
TO TAKE SOME PRECAUTIONS TO
MANAGE ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN
RISK THE SENATE CONTINUES TO
WELCOME THE PUBLIC. AND HAS
PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH IN
PERSON AND TELECONFERENCE
DISSIPATION FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX.
EIGHT ONE SIX THREE AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO TWO
FOUR. SIX TWO. I WILL REPEAT
THAT ARE PROBABLY A COUPLE MORE
TIMES TODAY. FOR THE PUBLIC
WHO'S TUNING IN. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF OUR HARD WORKING A
COURT REPORTER I'M GOING TO ASK
ALL SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES AND
WITNESSES ALIKE TO SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY LEE. IF I INTERRUPT
YOU IT WILL BE JUST TO SLOW YOU
DOWN OR ASK FOR CLARIFICATION
SO- BEAR WITH US AND I
APPRECIATE THAT- BEFORE WE BEGIN
TODAY'S AGENDA WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. AS A
REMEMBER REMINDER HOPEFULLY I'M
NOT GOING TO HAVE A PROBLEM
SPEAKING TODAY IT SEEMS I AM
FORGIVE M. AS A REMINDER
MEMBERS YOU WILL NEED TO TURN ON
YOUR MICROPHONE THE ROLL CALL
AND EVERY TIME THAT WE DO A VOTE
. SO MADAM SECRETARY WITHOUT
WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HERE HERE HERE BATES HERE BATES
HERE ATKINS HERE ATKINS HERE
THANK YOU- AND IS IT SENATOR
GROW WILL ALSO BE HERE- JUST AS
A REMINDER TO THE PUBLIC I HAVE
TO MEMBERS OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE THAT ALSO SET SIT ON
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE AND- THEY
HAVE TO COME AND GO AS IS
REQUIRED BY THEIR- THEIR DUTIES
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
YOU KNOW- THEY MAY BE ANOTHER
COMMITTEE IT AND SO THEY WILL BE
BACK AND FORTH- IF THERE'S NO.
OBJECTIONS I'D LIKE TO TAKE UP.
FIRST ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR. THAT WOULD
BE ITEM TWO F. R. EXCUSE ME.
THAT'S CORRECT US THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THE ASSISTANCE- IN
THE FUTURE. MOMENTS OF TROUBLE
TODAY TO F. IS A GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE NOT REQUIRED TO APPEAR
IT IS STEVEN KANALI A MEMBER OF
THE CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD ON MADAM CHAIR I WOULD
MOVEOUT OF. SENATOR LAYERED
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY A
MOTION HAS BEEN MADE WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL GROWTH
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER I LAYERED
HI THERE I BATES AYE BATES AYE
ATKINS AYE ATKINS AYE WHAT IS
YOUR ON CALL WE WILL PUT THAT ON
CALL- AND WE SAT I WOULD GO NEXT
TO ITEMS THREE THROUGH FIVE THAT
IS THE REFERENCE OF BILLS TO
COMMITTEES. AND FOR
ACKNOWLEDGMENTS AND ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. OUR WOULD MOVE ITEMS
THREE THROUGH FIVE AND I WILL IT
IS CENTER DELIVERED THANK YOU
BUT I HEARD THE VICE CHAIR FIRST
TO MY TO MY RIGHT. SO OUR MOTION
BY OUR VICE CHAIR SENATOR BATES
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GROVE KAMLAGER HI
KAMLAGER I FEARED HI THERE I
BATES ALL RIGHT IT'S AYE ATKINS
AYE ARE CONCERNED WHAT IS YOUR
ON CALL THAT IS ON CALL THANK
YOU. SO WE WILL NOW TURN TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR AND TAKE UP ITEM ONE
A. THE APPOINTMENT OF DAVID E.
SCRIBNER J. D. AS DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT. AND I
WANT TO SAY WELCOME TO YOU
DIRECTOR DONNA AND INVITE YOU TO
INTRODUCE YOURSELF ANYONE THAT
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
YOUR WHO ALSO MIGHT BE WITH YOU.
ARE WE WELCOME THOSE
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS AN OPENING
COMMENTS AND THEN AFTER THAT-
INTRODUCTION BY YOURSELF I WILL
GO TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS AND SO.
WITH THAT I SAY WELCOME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M
HONORED TO BE CONSIDERED AS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND WHILE.
I'M JOINED VIRTUALLY BY MY
FATHER JAMES DAUGHTER AMBER SONS
CHRISTIAN TYLER AS WELL AS MY
WIFE LISA. WHY MEASURE NEVER
THOUGHT SHE WOULD BE WATCHING
THE TODAY WITH THIRTY YEARS AGO
WE MET. I ANSWERED A QUESTION OF
WHAT DO YOU DO FOR A LIVING WITH
THAT I PLAN ON BEING A LAWYER.
ALSO ONE OF THE GOVERNORS OF THE
SECRETARY GALLAGHER WAS
APPOINTED IN GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE
CALIFORNIANS IN THIS ROLE. I
BEGAN MY CAREER STAFFCOUNSEL
FOR THE COMMISSION ON STATE
MANDATES. WANTED TO USE MY LEGAL
TRAINING TO SERVE OTHERS. AND
OVER THE PAST TWENTY THREE
YEARS. I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO JUST THAT. FIRST IN PUBLIC
SERVICE. BEFORE VENTURING OUT
INTO THE PRIVATE SECTOR. I'M
PROUD OF THE COUNTRY
CONTRIBUTIONS I MADE IN THOSE
SMALL MOMENTS. IN THIS
APPOINTMENT IS BROUGHT MY CAREER
FULL CIRCLE. TO ONCE AGAIN BE
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK IN
THE PUBLIC SECTOR. TO MAKE A
POSITIVE IMPACT IN OTHERS LIVES
. I'M VERY FORTUNATE TO GET TO
WORK WITH AN AMAZING GROUP OF
DEDICATED INDIVIDUALS HERE AT
CST AS WELL AS WITHIN OUR
NETWORK OF NONPROFIT AND PUBLIC
SECTOR SUB GRANTEES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. THROUGH THIS AMAZING
GROUP. BOTH WITH THE DEPARTMENT
AND OUR NETWORK. I'M EXCITED TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO USE MY
EXPERTISE EXPERIENCE AND ENERGY
. WHAT A POSITIVE IMPACT TO
THOSE CALIFORNIA'S THE
DEPARTMENT SERVES. THANK YOU I
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS
THIS AFTERNOON. WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND- IF OKAY- SENATOR
COME UNDER I MAY START WITH YOU
GIVEN THAT I NEVER KNOW WHEN YOU
MIGHT HAVE TO EXIT- SO GO READY
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEN BECAUSE
I TO NEVER KNOW WHEN I MAY BE
EXITING. EVEN IF I AM STILL
HERE. I IT IS A PLEASURE TO HAVE
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO ASK YOU SOME
QUESTIONS- DIRECTOR SCRIBNER
AND- APOLOGIES THAT WE WERE NOT
ABLE TO FIT SOME TIME AND- IN
TWO. MARK OUR CALENDARS TO MEET
PRIOR. TO TODAY I JUST HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS I THINK
THAT- THE WORK THAT COMES OUT
OF- CST IS. INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
I MEAN MY GOODNESS HOW WE CAN
WORK AS A STATE TO ALLEVIATE
ELIMINATE POVERTY I THINK THAT
SHOULD BE TASK NUMBER ONE FOR
ALL OF US- AND SO THE PROGRAMS.
THAT YOU ADMINISTER ARE
INCREDIBLY. RIGHTEOUS I HAD A
COUPLE QUESTIONS ONE IS AROUND-
THE COW EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
CAL EITC- I KNOW THERE HAVE BEEN
LOTS OF DISCUSSIONS AROUND HOW
TO EXPAND THE USE OF THE I. T.
C. AND I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW YOUR
THOUGHTS ON WAYS IN WHICH WE CAN
DO IT. I'M AND- WE'VE ALSO
LEARNED THAT THERE ARE SOME
CHALLENGES WITH CAL HE ITC'S
COMPATIBILITY WITH ITS FEDERAL
COUNTERPART. SO A WHAT ARE SOME
pTHINGS THAT CAN BE DONE TO
ELIMINATE- THE AREAS OF
INCOMPATIBILITY SO THAT WE CAN
DO MORE TO GET WHAT IS DUE TO-
THE- WORKING POOR AND POOR
CALIFORNIANS AS POSSIBLE AND
THEN B. HOW CAN WE WORK TO
EXPAND ITS USE SO IT CAN DO MORE
GOOD. I REALLY APPRECIATE ARE
THE QUESTION I TELL YOU WHAT YOU
SEE I AGREE WITH YOU IT IS ONE
OF OUR SHE- ADDED POVERTY
PROGRAMS HERE IN THE STATE- AND
THANK YOU FOR PRO TAB BACK IN
THE DAY FOR STARTING OUT OF THE-
STATE'S FIRST OUT YEAH IDC.
GRANT PROGRAMS. NO I THINK THAT
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE WERE
RESTARTED IN TWENTY FIFTEEN TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE WE ARE NOW-
AFTER LAST ROUND OF NUMBERS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TWENTY
FIFTEEN WE SAW ROUGHLY THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
GRANTS- SEAT TALLY I TO SEE-
GRANTS GO OUT FOR ROUGHLY ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. AND
THROUGH THE COOPERATION COME
COOPERATION BETWEEN CST THE
FEDERAL THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
AS WELL AS OUR REGIONAL PARTNERS
WE'RE WORKING RIGHT NOW UNITED
WAYS OF CALIFORNIA. AND SO I
THINK THAT THE WHEN WE LOOK AT
OUR CURRENT NUMBERS. WE GO FROM
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND THE FOUR POINT TWO
MILLION. AND OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
GRANTS ARE BEING EXPANDED SO I
THINK THAT THERE'S BEEN A REAL
STRONG STEADY GROWTH OVER THE
PAST SIX YEARS. THIS YEAR'S
YEARS BEEN ADMINISTERING CAL YET
YOU SEE WHAT I ABSOLUTELY AGREE
WITH YOU THAT WOULD THERE'S
ALWAYS THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
BETTER AND TO GET. THE AWARENESS
OUT AND I THINK THAT. THAT'S THE
BIGGEST STRUGGLE THAT WE'RE
HAVING AND WE DON'T WNT TO LOSE
SIGHT OF THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
CALIFORNIANS OUT THERE. THAT DO
NOT FILE TAXES. BUT COULD
BENEFIT FROM THE DOLLARS AND
SHOULD BENEFIT. SO I THINK THAT
THROUGH OUR REGION OUR REGIONAL
PARTNERS- THAT WE CAN'T CONTINUE
TO WORK ON MAKING AN AWARENESS
AND- OUTREACH. ONE OF THE
PRIMARY GOALS EACH AND EVERY
YEAR NOT JUST THE FREE TAX PREP
NOT JUST LETTING PEOPLE KNOW
THAT THERE'S DALY THE CHILD
CREDIT AS WELL NOT JUST DOING
THE I. TEN PORTION OF IT. THAT'S
ALL GREAT OF YOU KNOW ASPECTS OF
CALLIE IDC. BUT IF WE'RE NOT
GETTING THE PEOPLE THAT NEED IT.
FILING AND TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THESE THESE AMAZING CREDIT- YOU
KNOW WE ARE NOT DOING ALL THAT
WE CAN AND IT IS I THINK AN
ONGOING OPPORTUNITY TO BE
BETTER. AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OUR PARTNERS TO REALLY
WORK ON THAT OUTRAGE TO CONTINUE
TO SEE THESE NUMBERS GROW. FROM
THREE HUNDRED TO FIVE THOUSAND
THE TWENTY FIFTEEN TO FOUR POINT
TWO MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
I THINK IS SHOWS. THAT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO MAKING THIS
PROGRAM. AS WELL KNOWN AND AS
EXPOSURE RICH AS POSSIBLE AND
WILL CONTINUE TO FIND WAYS. TO
OPEN THOSE DOORS TO THOSE
CALIFORNIANS THAT ABSOLUTELY CAN
AND WOULD BENEFIT FROM THESE
DOLLARS. BUT MAY NOT KNOW ABOUT
IT OR MAY NOT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY- TO GET FILING AND
RECEIVED THE DELEGATION TO SEE
GRANT. I AGREE WHOLEHEARTEDLY- I
THINK THERE'S SO MUCH MORE THAT
CAN BE DONE AND POSSIBILITIES
AND THE OPPORTUNITIES ARE
IMMENSE. YOU KNOW I KNOW MY
BUDGET SUB FOR COMMITTEE WE DID
HAVE A HEARING ON THIS AND I
THERE ARE PARTNERS ACROSS THE
STATE THAT ARE. I THINK WORKING
OF THEIR SELVES OFF- TO. GET
THIS INFORMATION OUT TO THE
COMMUNITIES AND IT'S- THEY WITH
THERE'S STILL MORE THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE SO I WOULD JUST I THINK
THAT THERE ARE WE SHOULD NOT
JUST BE LEANING ON THOSE
PARTNERS IN MAKING SURE THAT
THEY'RE DOING MORE OUTREACH
BECAUSE- FROM MY WHAT I WAS ABLE
TO READ AND ASCERTAIN THEY ARE
DOING QUITE A BIT- THERE. ARE
HARD TO REACH FAMILIES. THAT ARE
NOT GETTING THE INFORMATION OR
DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE SHARING
INFORMATION THAT'S NEEDED OR
DON'T KNOW ABOUT IT- AND SO ARE
THERE YOU TALK ABOUT PARTNERS
ONE OF OUR BIGGEST PARTNERS AS A
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ARE THERE
WAYS THAT WE CAN LEAN ON THEM. I
THINK THE- YOU KNOW I THINK
INITIALLY WELL THE DEPARTMENT
WOULD LIKE TO DO AGAIN IS EXPAND
OUT REALLY AREN'T OUR OWN
NETWORK OUTREACH THROUGH BOTH
OUR C. S. B. G. SUB GRANTEES AS
WELL AS OUR LIFE HE GRANT- IT
CERVANTES BECAUSE THEY ARE
REALLY THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND
IN THE COMMUNITIES KNOWING FROM
THE BOTTOM UP WHAT THESE
COMMUNITIES NEED. AND IN DOING
THAT ONGOING OUTREACH AND REALLY
TRYING TO REACH LIKE YOU SAID IT
YOU KNOW I THINK THE THING IS
THAT THERE IS A LARGE PART OF
THESE ARE THE INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES THAT COULD BENEFIT
FROM. THIS PROGRAM. I'M JUST
QUITE FRANKLY AFRAID TO PUT THAT
TRUST AND FAITH. IN THE
GOVERNMENT TO YOU KNOW. BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES FOR THEM
AND I THINK I THINK IT'S JUST IT
IS A STRUGGLE. BUT WHEN WE- WHEN
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH- THE
CBO SAID THAT THE- THAT SOME OF
OUR PARTNERS THAT IN THE MIGRANT
SEASONAL FARM WORKER- ROUND
WHICH IS B. G. WITH- LIKE.
PRETTY WELL YOU KNOW THESE
AGENCIES THAT REALLY ARE IN PART
OF THOSE OMMUNITIES WHERE THE
STRUGGLE IS VERY REAL. TO GET
THEM TO COME OUT THE TRUST THAT
THESE SERVICES- THEY CAN AVAIL
THEMSELVES- TO. I REALLY THINK
THAT DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD WE CAN WE
CAN ABSOLUTELY LEVERAGE- AND
PROVIDE THOSE LINKAGES THAT ARE
OUR CURRENT NETWORK COUNTS. IN
THAT THEY DO ON THE DAILY. A
THANK YOU FOR THAT I WAS TAKEN
OUT- I'M- ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT
YOU HAVE- AND THIS IS MY LAST
QUESTION- MANY OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT YOU ADMINISTER- YOU KNOW
HAVE VERY SIMILAR PROGRAM
OBJECTIVES. AND SO JUST
WONDERING YOUR THOUGHTS ON YOU
KNOW WAYS THAT WE CAN MAXIMIZE
BENEFITS TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
WHILE MINIMIZING DUPLICATION OF
EFFORT- BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CARES ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING WHAT WE NEED OUT
TO CALIFORNIANS IN A WAY THAT
ISN'T DUPLICATIVE- OR OVER
BURDENSOME TO BUREAUCRACY DO YOU
HAVE ANY THOUGHTS. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY I THINK THAT'S A
GREAT POINT TO MAKE AND- I WOULD
SAY THAT ON THE SRFACE A LOT OF
IT COULD APPEAR THAT THE KIND OF
SHARE THE SAME SPACE. BUT WHEN
WE DIG A LITTLE DEEPER INTO
THESE POGRAMS FOR EXAMPLE THE
COMMUNITY SERVICES BLOCK GRANT
IS AN AMAZING FUNDING SOURCE
THAT CAN'T PROVIDE LINKAGES
LINKAGES ON LEVERAGING. ACROSS
VARIOUS DIFFERENT AREAS I'M NOT
JUST SERVICES BUT ALSO OUTCOMES
YOU KNOW TALKING ABOUT PROVIDING
FUNDING FOR FOOD BANKS BUT THEN
ALSO. ON THE JOB TRAINING OR
RESIDENCY TRAINING WHERE SOMEONE
MIGHT WRITE AN AMAZING RESUME
AND GET A JOB AND HAVE THIS
AMAZING OUTCOME. OF FROM THAT
LINKAGE THAT C. S. B. G. IS
BRING IN FOR. OUR LOW INCOME
HOME ENERGY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
LIE HE FOR EXAMPLE YES IT HAS
THE WEATHER IS ATION SIDE OF THE
HOUSE AND WE DO HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY WHETHER
THEY SHOULD DISTANCE PROGRAM AS
WELL. AND THIS YEAR WE ARE
FORTUNATE TO BE IN RECEIVING OF
A LOT OF MONEY UNDER THE DEAL WE
PROGRAM FOR WEATHER IS ASIAN.
BUT THEY HAVE A BOWLS AND WE'VE
BEEN FORTUNATE TO WORK WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS. TO BOTH A LOT
THE DEPARTMENT OR THE WEATHER
SYSTEMS PROGRAM WITH THE LOW
INCOME HOME ENERGY ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM SO THAT THERE ARE. IS
THE LEVER. THE GREAT WORK.
HOLISTIC STOP THE WORD BUT- MORE
COME- OF YOU KNOW- OPPORTUNITY
FOR THOSE LOW INCOME CALIFORNIA
I CAN AVAIL THEMSELVES OF THESE
PROGRAM BUT NOT ONLY ARE PROBE.
THE INCOME PROGRAM THAT IS STATE
FUNDED BY CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS
AGAIN THAT HAS A VERY SPECIFIC
PURPOSE BUT WE BOTH WE HAVE
HOLDEN ON MULTI FAMILY AS WELL
AS MIGRANT SEASONAL FARMWORKERS
SO WHILE THERE IS WEATHER IS
ATION THEIR SOLAR PEAVEY
HAPPENING UNDER THE LAW THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM OF
THE STATE CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS.
THERE ARE FOCUSED SPECIFICALLY
TO HELP A PARTICULAR SET OF
CALIFORNIANS- THAT DESPERATELY
NEED THIS WORK AND I THINK
FINALLY IT REALLY THAT KIND OF
BRINGS IT ALL TOGETHER IS THE
CALIFORNIA REPAIR PROGRAM WHERE
THE DEPARTMENT WAS ABLE TO GET A
BILLION DOLLARS OUT THE DOOR IN
JUST OVER SIX MONTHS WITH NO
AUGMENTATION TO STAFF I DO KNOW
I'M HAPPY TO SEE SB STEP ON THE
BACK. ABSOLUTELY AMAZING I AM
STILL IN SHOCK THAT WE WERE ABLE
TO ACHIEVE- IT BUT THAT PROGRAM
EIGHT AS WELL HELP YOU TO REARED
. AND REALLY HELPED FOLK. IN ON
WHAT CALIFORNIANS NEED IN THIS
SPACE NOT ONLY JUST A UTILITY
SUPPORT. BUT ALSO WHETHER IS
ASIAN BUT I THINK YOU CAN SEE
WANTS TO KIND OF DIVE INTO THESE
PROGRAMS. THE DEPARTMENT IS VERY
VERY AWARE OF THE POTENTIAL FOR
DUPLICATION. AND WE HELP AND
DESIGNED OUR STATE PROGRAMS OR
WORK WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS.
TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE THESE.
SEPARATIONS THAT WHEN WE LINK
THEM TOGETHER CREATES A WHOLE
LOT MORE COMPLETE- APPLICATION
OF THE SERVICES AND DOLLARS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT- I CAN I CAN
SEE YOUR PASSION FOR THIS WORK-
RADIATING THROUGH THE TV SCREEN.
SO WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SUPPORT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF MEADOW VICE
CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO NEXT
THANK YOU. WELL THANK YOU ARE
DIRECTORS. SCRIBNER FOR STEPPING
UP AND OBVIOUSLY ARE YOUR
BACKGROUND SUGGESTS THAT YOU ARE
VERY ARE WELL EQUIPPED TO TAKE
ON THIS NEW RESPONSIBILITY SO
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT ON. MY THE GOVERNOR
I JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS ON KNOWING THAT. THE
BULLS OF THE COMMUNITY SERVICES-
IN DEVELOPMENT- IS TO REDUCE
POVERTY SO ONE OF MY QUESTIONS
IS. YOU ARE THE PROGRAMS ARE
DESIGNED TO HELP PEOPLE ACHIEVE
SELF SUFFICIENCY HAVING WON THE
TOP HONOR TIME BEEN A SOCIAL
WORKER THAT WAS ALWAYS MY GOAL
IN WITH MY CASELOAD BUT- DO YOU
HAVE- IN ACCOUNTABILITY
DASHBOARD OF ANY SORT TO WHERE
YOU. ARE CAN MEASURE WHETHER THE
PROGRAMS ARE HELPING INDIVIDUALS
INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES ACHIEVE
SELF SUFFICIENCY. AND IF NOT.
HOW WOULD YOU GO IN THAT
DIRECTION SO THAT THE MANY THAT
IS THERE FOR YOU ALL FOR THOSE
SPECIFIC PURPOSE. WE HAVE A
MEASURE OF BEST PRACTICES AND
GIVE YOU ACTUALLY THE DATA. SAID
HE A DIP ACTION IF THAT WOULD BE
NEEDED. WELL ABSOLUTELY THAT
DOVETAILS REALLY INTO- YOU KNOW
THE THREE MAIN GOALS THAT I
REALLY WANT TO ACHIEVE HERE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT WHEN ALL THREE.
CENTER AROUND. THE DEPARTMENT
AND AS NETWORK. BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES IN THE BEST WAY
POSSIBLE FOR THOSE CALIFORNIANS
THEY NEED IT. AND IT REALLY IS
TO TAKE A LOOK AT. OUR DATA WHAT
WE HAVE HOW CAN WE GET TO IT AND
I THINK THAT- WE ARE IN THE
CURRENT PLANNING STAGES OF
OPERATING AND MOVING OFF OF OLD
LEGACY SYSTEMS AND TO MORE
ROBUST CURRENT SYSTEMS. SO THAT
WE REALLY CAN USE DATA TO DRIVE
OUR DECISION MAKING. I THINK THE
SECOND POINT OF THAT I THINK IS
JUST AS IMPORTANT AS
UNDERSTANDING THE DATA WE NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THE PEOPLE AND SO
I'D LIKE TO GET A BASELINE OF
WHERE WE STAND WITH FIRST CITY.
AND IN. EQUITY AND- IN IT'S JUST
IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND IF WE ARE.
GOING TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES FROM THE DEPARTMENT
LEVEL THAT WE'RE DOING SO WITH
COMPASSION AND EMPATHY AND
UNDERSTANDING. THE DIVERSITY
WITHIN THE- THEY IN. THAT ARE
THERE IN A JUSTICE IS THAT MAYBE
THERE AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
AS THE DEPARTMENT THAT WE MODEL
THE WAY. AND THAT WE CAN HELP
OUR AGENCIES. UNDERSTAND THE
VALUES THAT THE DEPARTMENT AND
THE STATE TAKES WITH THOSE-
PARTICULAR INITIATIVES. BUT THEN
WE ALSO WANT TO A BASELINE OF
WHERE OUR AGENCIES- I KNOW THAT
MANY OF THEM HAVE SPENT MANY
MANY YEARS- ON. D. E. I. KNOW
JAKE WE CALL IT CHEN I HEAR THE
STATE THEY DO D. E. I. J. LOCAL
LEVEL I LIKE THE JET I WON YOU
KNOW JUST LISTEN YOU KNOW
EQUITY. DIVERSITY INCLUSION BUT-
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME THAT
HAVE REALLY REALLY ROBUST
PROGRAMS IN PLACE AND I WANT TO
FIND A WAY. TO DO THE EASY THING
LET'S JUST REPLICATE WHAT WORKS
LET'S FIND THE HOLES THAT WE
HAVE FILL THEM AND TAKE THE
STEPS FORWARD. AND THEN FINALLY
WHAT I'D LIKE US TO DO IS
CONTINUE TO THE COLLABORATION
WITH OUR NETWORK WE NEED TO HAVE
OPEN HONEST EASY COMMUNICATIONS
AND BY DOING THOSE THREE THINGS.
I THINK THAT WHAT WE WILL
ACHIEVE. IS A BETTER SENSE OF.
WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH THE
DOLLARS OF THE LOCAL LEVEL. WHAT
AND WHO IS BENEFITING FROM THE-
HOW WE CAN POTENTIALLY BE BETTER
AND WE ALWAYS CAN EVERY SINGLE
YEAR THERE'S ALWAYS
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE BETTER. AND
THEN USE THOSE DECISION A DATA
POINTS THE FOCUS ON THE PERSON.
AND THEN THAT WAY WE ARE MAKING
SURE THAT WE'RE DOING THE
ABSOLUTE BEST WE CAN WITH THE
DOLLARS AT HAND. BUT IT IS A
PROCESSAND RIGHT NOW TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION QUITE BLUNTLY WE
HAVEA LOT OF DATA. AND WE ARE
STRUGGLING TO PASS YOU KNOW AND-
GET THE BEST USED OUT OF IT AND
THAT IS AND IT'S NOT GOING
STRUGGLING AND WE WILL BE BETTER
WITH IT AND I THINK EVERY SINGLE
YEAR WE DO PROVIDE BETTER DATA
POINTS FOR BOTH. THE PARTNERS SO
THAT THEY HAVE A GOOD SENSE OF
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT AND WHERE
THEY'RE COMING FROM AND WHAT
THEY'RE DOING WITH THOSE
DOLLARS. AT THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
LEVEL. WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT
RESPONSE AND NOW YOU HIT ON A
NUMBER OF THE THINGS THAT WOULD
BE FOLLOW UP THOUGHT TO MY
QUESTION SO I WON'T GO THERE. I
JUST WANT TO APPLAUD YOU FOR THE
PASSION THAT YOU DO SHOW UP FOR
YOUR ASSIGNMENT- THIS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT JOB. VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE WITH OUR LOW INCOME PEOPLE
WHO DO STRUGGLE TO MEET THE
BASIC GONNA NEED THE LIGHT. ON
THIS THE PART. ARE IS VERY MUCH-
OUT SAY A COMMON DENOMINATOR AND
HELPING THEM DO THAT SO. IT
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL I BELIEVETO US POLICYMAKERS IF THERE IS.
SOME SORT OF A- AN
ACCOUNTABILITY DASHBOARD SO THAT
IF THERE'S LEGISLATION THAT'S
NEEDED TO ADVANCE THE GOALS OF
OUR THE AGENCY THEN IT WE ARE
GOING TO BE ALL RIGHT. RIGHT IN
LINE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT AND
ENSURE THAT WE DO MEET THAT VERY
NOBLE GOAL- CERTAINLY. DELIV
PEOPLE AT. LEAST SO THAT THEY
CAN ACHIEVE SELF SUFFICIENCY AND
CERTAINLY ENJOY- THE GOLDEN
STATE. SO I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOU TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
SOME INTERACTION OB OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS TO SEE HOW
YOU'RE ACHIEVING THOSE GOALS
AND- ARE GETTING US WHERE WE ALL
WANT TO BE SO THANK YOU. AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR DEDICATION TO
THIS PUBLIC SERVICE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ONE. THANK YOU MADAM
VICE CHAIR I WILL- GO TO SENATOR
LAYERED NEXT AND A KNOWLEDGE
THAT SENATOR GROWTH HAS MADE IT
OVER FROM THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
FOR A BIT BUT- CENTER LAYERED
ALL LET HER GET HER. SEA LEGS
AND YOU GO AHEAD OVER HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IN. OUR THIS
IS ONE OF THOSE SITUATIONS WHERE
THE PREVIOUS TWO- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ASKED MOST OF THE THINGS
I WAS GOING TO. LET ME THANK YOU
FOR MEETING WITH ME THIS MORNING
AND- LET ME ASK ONE QUESTION.
ARE THAT I THINK THE U.
PARTIALLY ADDRESSED WITH SENATOR
COM WALKER BUT MAYBE I'LL ASK IT
A DIFFERENT WAY AND THAT THAT.
ARM TO RECEIVE MORE THAN A-
DOLLARS OF FUNDING IN THE BUDGET
THIS YEAR AS A SIGNIFICANT ONE
TIME AUGMENTATION- WHAT DID YOU
FOR THE CHALLENGES DID YOU FACE
IN GETTING IT OUT THE DOOR. AND-
WHAT YOU LEARN AND IT HAS IT
ACCOMPLISHED WHAT YOU'D HOPED IT
WOULD IN ONE OF WAS ALLOCATED IN
YOU ARE PUSHING IT OUT THE DOOR
. YEAH YOU FOR THE QUESTION IS
AND THANK YOU FOR. ITS KNOWLEDGE
AND YOU KNOW THIS SMALL
DEPARTMENT OF RECEIVING A B.
YEAH IT'S- QUITE A LARGE AMOUNT
OF MONEY THEN IN A SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME TO ACHIEVE OUR GOALS.
YEAH I LOOK AT IT NOW AND I
THINK THAT WAS EASY FOR ME TO DO
THAT EVERY YEAR BUT- IT. IS
CHILDREN'S OF COURSE WE WERE
ABLE TO NOT ONLY SPIN UP A BRAND
NEW PROGRAM DEVELOP POLICIES-
THE LEGISLATURE WAS WAS GRACIA.
HELLO US TO. DO A- APPROACH THAN
HAVING TO DO READ. WE WOULD
NEVER BEEN ABLE TO MEET OUR
TIMELINES OF WE HAD TO GO
THROUGH THE REGULATORY PROCESS.
AND I THINK THAT WAS A THAT WAS
A GREAT. OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
BE NIMBLE CREATIVE THINK OUTSIDE
THE BOX. AND I THINK THE OTHER.
WE UNDERSTAND OF ALL NEW ID
PROGRAM. WE HAD TO STAND UP NEW
ACCOUNTING SYSTEMS YOU KNOW IT
WAS IT WAS QUITE A LIST FOR
SURE- BUT I THINK THAT BY MARCH.
WELL I DON'T THINK I KNOW HE DID
IT WITHOUT ADDING A SINGLE
PERSON TO THE DEPARTMENT. WE
CAME IN UNDER THE TIMELINE WE
HAD MINISTER EVERY SINGLE DOLLAR
THAT WE COULD ADMINISTER. AND
THOSE DOLLARS WHEN OUT THERE ARE
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS TO THE TWO NINE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. TO PAY DOWN UTILITY
AVERAGES. ON THE SHELVES I
THINK. MORE THAN ANYTHING WAS.
JUST ANNOUNCED THAT. THE IS THAT
I CAN'T SAY ENOUGH I WORK WAS
SUCH AN AMAZING GROUP OF ALL
STARS YOU KNOW WE ALWAYS TALK
ABOUT HOW. WE'RE THE SMALL BUT
MIGHTY- DEPARTMENT BUT EVERYONE
OF A ROCK STARS YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT PULLING ANYBODY OUT OF. OF A
SMALL CLUB THERE ALREADY WHERE
YOU KNOW AND SO I THINK THE- MR
CASE. THAT WORK IN THIS PART
BECAUSE OF OUR SIZE YOUR CLOSE.
TO SEE THE IMPACTS OF THE
DECISIONS AND THAT THE POLICIES
AND THE THINGS THAT WE DO IN OUR
NETWORK DOES EVERY SINGLE DAY. I
THINK IT GIVES A REALLY A CLEAR
LENS AND AN IMPETUS. TO MAYBE GO
A LITTLE BIT FURTHER A LITTLE
BIT HARDER AND I KNOW. MY ENTIRE
TEAM DID THAT FOR SIX MONTHS.
NOW I DON'T THINK THAT OBVIOUSLY
WE CAN DO THAT EVERY YEAR WE TRY
OF COURSE- BUT I THINK THE BEARS
ARE THE BIGGEST OBSTACLE-
SENATOR WAS JUST REALLY NOT
HAVING TIME IF WE IF WE COULD-
WE WILL RESPOND UP LITTLE SMALL
DIVISION AND ADDED A FEW PEOPLE
AND IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A LITTLE
RICHER. BUT WE HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY LET ME. LET ME ASK A
FOLLOW UP HOW WOULD YOU MEASURE.
WHAT THE OUTCOMES WERE FROM THE
- BILLION DOLLARS THAT YOU GOT
OUT THE DOOR. ARE YOU TALK ABOUT
THE PROCESS OF GETTING. HOW
WOULD YOU ACTUALLY MEASURE COMES
. WELL THE OUTCOMES ARE NOW WE
ARE CURRENTLY BEING MEASURED BUT
THE OUTCOME IS DIRECTLY
SERVICING ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS RECEIVING A CAPS
LOCK YOUR CALIFORNIA RICH
PAYMENT PLAN PROGRAM BENEFIT ON
THEIR UTILITY BILL WITHIN SIXTY
DAYS OF THE OF THE MONEY BEING
DISTRIBUTED TO THEIR PARTICULAR
UTILITY. AGAIN NINE HUNDRED
NINETY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
WERE APPLIED TO- UTILITY
AVERAGES AND SO CURRENT. WE ARE
GOING THREE OH WHAT IS BEEN
DEEMED THE CLOSE OUT PROCESS BUT
WE ARE PERFORMING AUDITS OF
UTILITIES WE ARE- MAKING SURE
THAT THROUGH THAT ON A PROCESS
THAT PAYMENTS ARE MADE AS THEY
WERE SUPPOSED TO BE. AND WE WILL
BE GETTING REPORTING BACK FROM
YOU USUALLY OF WHEN THEY WERE
PAID HOW THAT MONEY WENT WHO IT
WENT TO. WE DON'T KNOW WHO IT A
IT'S A NON OPTIMIZED BY
ACCOUNTS. BUT THEN WE WILL BE
ABLE TO AGGREGATE THAT DATA AND-
PROVIDE THE FIFTY DATA POINTS
THAT'S IN THE GOVERNMENT. I
REPORT TO PRESENTABLE. SHOW YOU
EXACTLY. WHAT WE CREATED HOW WE
DID IT WHEN IT HAPPENS AND IN
THE END RESULT BUT I THINK THE
END RESULT OF RIGHT NOW IS WHAT
WE ABSOLUTELY NO ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE BENEFITED TO THE
TUNE OF NINE HUNDRED NINETY
THREE MILLION DOLLARS AND PAY
DOWN THEIR UTILITY REGION'S.
THANKS VERY MUCH REALLY
APPRECIATE- AGAIN YOUR MEETING
AND- RESPONSIVENESS TO THE
QUESTIONS I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING. THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED- SENATOR GROWTH THANK
YOU MADAM FOR TEN. AM THANK YOU
MISTER SCRIBNER FOR BEING- HERE
TODAY AND- I TO LOOK FORWARD TO
VOTING FOR YOUR APPOINTMENT I DO
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS THOUGH I
DID LIKE ALL THE INFORMATION
THAT YOU SUBMITTED TO THE RULES
PACKET AND- I DO ESPECIALLY LIKE
THE COMMENTS THAT YOU MADE A
JUST A MINUTE AGO WHEN YOU WERE
TALKING AND YOU TALKED ABOUT
ROCKSTAR TEAMS AND YOU TALKED
ABOUT. EVEN IN THE MIDST OF
IMPLEMENTING A NEW I. T. PROGRAM
LIFTING UP- YOU KNOW IN A NEW
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET THAT HAD
TO BE DISTRIBUTED OUT. IN THE
ROOM TO DO THAT WITH WE SAID
NINE HUNDRED NINETY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS WENT OUT
DIRECTLY TO THE CALIFORNIANS
THAT DESPERATELY NEED IT. AND
YOU TALKED ABOUT HOW YOU DID
THAT WITHOUT ADDING A SINGLE. M.
PERSON. ADD TO THE TEAM IN YOUR
TEAM DID IT FOR SIX MONTHS. AT
TO ME THAT'S EXTRAORDINARY AND I
APPRECIATE YOU CLAIMING YOUR
TEAM BUT- I DO BELIEVE AS WELL
IT COMES AND WITH. THE
DEMONSTRATION OF GREAT
LEADERSHIP SO THANK YOU FOR. AND
THE LEADERSHIP YOU PROVIDE TO
THIS DEPARTMENT. I DO HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS- AND I
APOLOGIZE IF MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ALREADY ASKED THESE QUESTIONS I
WAS IN HEALTH COMMITTEE SO I DO
APOLOGIZE. IF THIS IS
DUPLICATED. M. HOW IS THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE BLOCK GRANT
CHANGED IF AT ALL OVER THE
COURSE OF YOUR TENURE IN THE
DEPARTMENT AND DO YOU HAVE ANY
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
IMPROVE THE STATE'S
ADMINISTRATION OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDING SOURCE AND IF SO. CAN
YOU SHARE THAT INFORMATION. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY UNFORTUNATELY THAT
WASN'T A DUPLICATE. I WELCOME
THE QUESTION. I YOU KNOW I DON'T
THINK THAT THERE ARE YOU KNOW
THAT THE TEACHERS BLOCK GRANT
AGAIN IS SUCH AN AMAZING FUNDING
SOURCE AND IT'S AN AMAZING WAY
TO GET THE DOLLARS OUT THE DOOR
BECAUSE IT'S- INVERTED. IT'S A
BOTTOM UP APPROACH TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THOSE IN NEED IN THE
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY. IT IS
BASED ON COMMUNITY. THE NEEDS
ASSESSMENTS THAT ARE SUBMITTED
BY OUR SUB GRANTEES TO THE
DEPARTMENT. AND THEY ARE THE
ONES. OF THROUGH THAT NEEDS
ASSESSMENT THROUGH THEIR THEIR
COMMUNICATION PLANS THEY EVERY
YEAR IDENTIFIED THEIR GOALS. WE%
WANT TO ACHIEVE ACTS WE WANT TO
ACHIEVE WHY WANNA CHOOSY AND
THEN AT THE END OF THE YEAR. WE
SEE HOW WE DID. AND SO I THINK
THAT IT'S THE GREAT SUCCESS. OF
COMMUNITY ACTION IT'S THE GREAT
SUCCESS OF OUR PUBLIC PARTNERS
AS WELL. I THINK IT'S WHITE
COMMUNITY THE COMMUNITY SERVICES
BLOCK GRANT HAS BEEN SO
SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE HONESTLY I
WOULDN'T CHANGE MUCH IF ANYTHING
THAT I WOULD DO BETTER AS A
DEPARTMENT. IS TO HELP SUPPORT
OUR NETWORK THROUGH BETTER DATA
GATHERING AND BETTER DATA
SHARING AND WE ARE WORKING ON
THAT BECAUSE WE CAN BE BETTER AT
THAT. BUT AGAIN AS A SOURCE.
BEING ABLE TO LEVERAGE AND
WRAPAROUND SERVICES IN ANY WAY
NECESSARY. DEPENDING ON THE
LOCATION IS REALLY AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT I WOULDN'T
TOUCH AND I DON'T THINK WE NEED
TO. WE JUST NEED TO MAKE SUREAS
A DEPARTMENT WE ARE UP
APPROPRIATELY ACCURATELY. AND
YOU KNOW PASSIONATELY THE
REALLY. WORKING COLLABORATIVELY
WITH WEATHER NETWORK SUPPORTING
THEM AND GIVING THEM THE TOOLS
THAT THEY NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
THANK YOU AND YOU ANSWERED MY
SECOND QUESTION BECAUSE I WAS
CURIOUS ABOUT HOW YOU SERVICE A
DIFFERENT AREAS BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THE ENTIRE STATE IS DIFFERENT
FROM ONE AREA TO THE OTHER IN
AND YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT DATA
DRIVEN. AND DECISIONS ON HOW TO
IMPLEMENT THAT IN YOUR RESPONSE
SO THANK YOU SIR VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU I CENTER GROVE I
THINK. A LOT OF GOOD QUESTIONS.
HAVE BEEN ASKED ABOUT MY
COLLEAGUES. I'M INTERESTED- YET
IN THE WORK WITH YOUR COMMUNITY
PARTNER AGENCIES- IN. YOUR
ONGOING RELATIONSHIP. HOW DO YOU
WORK WITH THEM IT'S TO THE POINT
THAT CENTER GROVE MADE UP AND
DOWN THE STATE DIFFERENT AREAS
DIFFERENT ISSUES. SO THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC THROUGH A FIRE
SITUATION. A FIRE RELATED NEEDS.
HOW DO YOU FIND WAYS TO WORK
DIFFERENTLY WITH THOSE PARTNERS
ANY EXAMPLES OR THINGS YOU WANT
TO SHARE WHERE YOU'RE ABLE TO.
BE FLUID FLEXIBLE AND- MOVE
DIFFERENTLY IN THIS AREA VERSES
THAT AREA BECAUSE I THINKING
GOVERNMENT. I'M IN THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS MATTER. BUT THE
OVERSIGHT OF HOW YOU DO THAT
GIVE ME ANY EXPERIENCES YOU.
THINK YOU MIGHT WANT TO STOP.
AND IT AND- WITH US TO HELP US
TO SEE HOW THOSE PARTNERS WORK.
YEAH THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
BECAUSE IT IS SUCH A PARTNER
BASED. APPROACH TO HELPING
ALLEVIATE POVERTY- AND LIFT UP
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS HERE IN
THE STATE. I THINK FIRST AND
FOREMOST THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING TO KEEP IN MIND IS THAT.
ALL OF THESE FEDERAL GRANTS ARE
BASED ON LOCAL CONTROL. IT IS IT
IS OUR LOCAL PARTNERS THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY DEPEND ON. TO DO
OUTREACH TO DO THEIR COMMUNITY
NEEDS ASSESSMENTS TO NARROW BY
BOOTS ON THE GROUND. WHAT
THEY'RE- NEIGHBORS NEED. AND SO
THAT THEY CAN ANNUALLY WITHIN G.
S. B. G. NOT SO MUCH WITH OUR
ALONG COME HOME ENERGY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. BUT THEY CAN
ADJUST- AS THEY THEY SEE- THOSE
THINGS CHANGE AND THE WAY THAT
WE I THINK ARE. ABLE TO BE
CREATIVE AND FLEXIBLE AT THE
DEPARTMENT LEVEL IS WITH C. S.
B. G. WE HAVE- IN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT MEETS REGULARLY.
AT ADDRESSES POLICY AND
PROGRAMMATIC CONCERNS AND SO WE
STATE TIED INTO- REALLY KIND OF
THE HIGH LEVEL OF THINGS THAT
THE DEPARTMENTS WORKING ON SOME
OF THE NETWORK INOTES. AND ON
THE ENERGY SIDE THOUGH THE LOW
INCOME HOME ENERGY ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM SIDE WE HAVE AN ENERGY
CAL'S THE SAME TYPE OF SET UP
WHERE WE HAVE OUR LOCAL PARTNERS
AND WE HAVE THESE DIALOGUES ON
ON THE REGULAR AND WHEN WE HAVE.
A NEW PROGRAM FOR EXAMPLE LIKE
THE IT'S GOT ANOTHER LOW INCOME
HOME WATER SYSTEMS PROGRAM THE
NEW WATER FEDERAL WATER PROGRAM
YEAH. WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
WITH OUR LOCAL PARTNERS TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS THE BEST
WAY THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE THE
GOALS OF THIS NEW PROGRAM. AND
NOT HAVE TO REINVENT THE WHEEL.
SINCE IT WAS A ONE TIME FUNDING
SOURCE OF THE HUNDRED SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS SO I THINK
HAVING THAT OPEN COMMUNICATION
AND WORKING COLLABORATIVELY. IS
REALLY. IS REALLY JUST THE CASE
FOR US. THANK YOU YOU KNOW I ONE
MORE QUESTION YOU TALKED ABOUT
FIVE DATA COLLECTION AND- I'M
JUST THINKING ABOUT THE NUMBER
OF LIVES THAT YOU POTENTIALLY
TOUCHING CALIFORNIA. THROUGH
YOUR PARTNERSHIPS. AND IT'S
ALMOST LIKE THAT YOU KNOW FROM
IN PARTICULAR I THINK ABOUT
THINGS LIKE- EMERGENCY NEEDS NOT
NECESSARY. SARALEE THE LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION BUT BUT
YEAH I. T. C. A U. WE UTILITIES
WATER ENERGY. YOU KNOW I SORT OF
WONDERED THERE'S A FRIGHTENING
PIECE OF THIS WHICH IS THE
GOVERNMENT KNOWS WHO YOU ARE BUT
IT BUT IN TERMS OF KNOWING WHERE
THERE ARE POTENTIALLY NEEDY
CONSTITUENTS AND RESIDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT NEED HELP- IF
THERE WERE A SITUATION WHERE WE
WANTED TO MAKE SURE DO OUTREACH
TO LET PEOPLE KNOW. THAT THEIR
RESOURCES FOR THIS CRITICAL
NEED- THAT CRITICAL NEED WOULD
YOUR DEPARTMENT BE ABLE TO DO
THAT. YES I BELIEVE SO AGAIN I
WOULD THINK IT WOULD REALLY
DEPEND ON WHAT THE PROGRAMMATIC
SHAPE OF THE DOLLARS LOOKS LIKE
. YOU KNOW OUR PARTNERS NETWORK
PARTNERS DO THAT ALL THE TIME
AND I THINK THAT AGAIN. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE NEEDS FAR
OUTPACES THE DOLLARS THAT WE
ADMINISTER EVERY YEAR AND THAT'S
UNFORTUNATE BUT THIS IS NOT AN
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM NONE OF OUR
PROGRAMS ARE. THEY ARE FIRST
COME SERVE APPROACH BUT I FEEL
VERY STRONGLY THAT OUR COMMUNITY
ACTION AGENCIES WITH C. S. B. G.
R. ENERGY GROUPS LOW INCOME HOME
ENERGY ASSISTANCE PROGRAM ON THE
ENERGY SIDE. ARE REALLY DIALED
INTO THEIR COMMUNITIES THEY KNOW
WHAT THE NEEDS ARE THEY KNOW
WHERE. SERVICES COULD BE
EXPANDED AND MOVED INTO-
DIFFERENT AREAS DIFFERENT ROUNDS
AND I THINK EVEN THE DEPARTMENT.
WERE VERY GOOD WITH PICKING
PARTNERS OF WE NEED TO DO A
REGIONAL APPROACH- TO- IN MISTER
PROGRAM WE DID THAT WITH OUR LOW
INCOME WEATHERIZATION PROGRAM
THE CAP AND TRADE FUNDED- GROUND
THAT. RESULT IN THE BACK WAS
HERALDED AS A GREAT MODEL A
STATE AND NATIONWIDE ON
ADMINISTERING A DOLLARS IN THAT
PARTICULAR WAY WE WORK WITH
REGIONAL PARTNERS WHO ARE ABLE
TO IDENTIFY NEEDS AND START AT.
YOU KNOW TAKING A BITE OUT OF
THE POVERTY PROBLEM IN TAKING A
BITE OUT OF. OF THE STRESS AND
ANXIETY THAT THAT LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS ARE THOSE ARE JUST
STRUGGLING EVEN AFTER THE
PANDEMIC MAY BE FEELING- AND
LETTING THEM KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SERVICES AVAILABLE. AND THEN IN
THE MONTHS WRAPAROUND SERVICES
THAT. WE DON'T PROVIDE LED HIM
INTO WHAT DOES SOCIAL SERVICES
ARE THERE AND OTHER PROGRAMS AS
WELL SO I THINK OUR NETWORK IS
REALLY REALLY GOOD. AT PROVIDING
THAT INFORMATION AND I THINK THE
DEPARTMENT IT. WITH WILL. TAKE
WHAT NEEDS LOCAL BUT TO THE BEST
THAT WE CAN FROM THE AS FAR AS
WE CAN STRETCH THE DOLLARS. TRY
TO DO AS MUCH AS YEAH. THANK I.
THINK A LOT- WE ARE GOING TO. GO
AHEAD AND GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. AND SO- I'M A DO A
QUICK REMINDER. THAT IF YOU WISH
TO PROVIDE COMMENT PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA PHONE- THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX
EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO TWO
FOUR SIX TWO. WE WILL TAKE
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT AFTER WE DO
OUR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THEATER HERE. IN PERSON SO I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE WERE
GEARED UP AND READY. TO MAKE
THEIR CALLS IF THEY WILL.
SERVICE START WITH WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED.
LET ME ASK PEOPLE TO RESPECT
DISTANCE IN SPACE BUT COME ON
FORWARD GIVE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION OF ANY AND YOUR
TESTIMONY I'M- GOOD AFTERNOON-
MICROBES IN HERE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION AND REALLY- CENTERS-
GROVE AND- LAYARD. COMMENTED ON
WHAT WHAT I'M NOT HERE TO TALK
ABOUT IS REALLY THAT THE ONE
BILLION DOLLAR- JUST PROGRAM FOR
UTILITY RELIGIOUS- THE
DEPARTMENT- STARTED THIS P. P.
GOT THIS MONEY. I GOT GOT THIS
PROGRAM UP AND RUNNING FROM
SCRATCH- DEMONSTRATED WHAT
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT IS
ACTUALLY CAPABLE OF WHEN WE AND
THAT ALL STARTS AT CENTER GROVE
SAID FROM WITH LEADERSHIP AND AS
A RESULT YOU KNOW WE REALLY WANT
TO- SUPPORT MISTER SPEAKER FOR
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER ROSEN I ANYONE
ELSE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED.
OKAY SEEING NO ONE ELSE IN
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WE WILL MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TEST
STUFF TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE. AND SO I'M GOING TO
WELCOME OUR MODERATOR AND ASK IF
YOU WILL PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS. ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR WILL QUICKLY GIVE YOU
THERE YOUR LINE NUMBER PLACE YOU
BACK INTO THE QUEUE SO IF YOU
ARE SUPPORT THESE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONE FOUR ZERO
THANK YOU N. NINE MISTER
MODERATOR IS PEOPLE ARE Q.
ENOUGH IF YOU WERE ABLE TO GIVE
ME THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING.
I AND THEN WE'LL GO AHEAD AND TO
THOSE WHO WILL BE TESTIFYING
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IF ANY
AND YOUR- POSITION IN SUPPORT.
BRIEFLY I DON'T CARE NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH ARE WE WILL BE
BACK WITH YOU IN JUST A MOMENT
I'M SURE- LET ME GO AHEAD AND GO
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO MAY
BE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED.
IN OPPOSITION ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY SEEING NO ONE
APPROACH THE- DYESS LET ME ASK
MR MODERATOR IF YOU WILL T.
FOLKS UP WHO MAY WISH TO SPEAK
VIA TELECONFERENCE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE FILED BY ZERO. AND
MADAM CHAIR NOBODY'S QUEUING UP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ARE WE WILL
TALK WITH YOU AGAIN SHORTLY. SO
LET ME SEE WHICH OF MY
COLLEAGUES WANTS TO JUMP
FORWARD- AND MAKE A MOTION. ON
THIS APPOINTMENT. US SENATOR
GROWTH. YEAH I'D LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION WITH I BELIEVE THE
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU MA'AM
SECRETARY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. GROOVE I GROUP
II AM LAGER I KAMLAGER HI THERE
HI THERE I EIGHT FIVE EIGHT AYE
ATKINS AYE A CONCISE. MISTER
SPRINGER CONGRATULATIONS AND I
HUGE THANKS FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
YOUR PASSION FOR THIS JOB WE
WILL MOVE YOUR APPOINTMENT ON TO
THE SENATE FULL SENATE FOR
CONFIRMATION CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
HAVE A GREAT REST OF YOUR DAY
SECRETARY WHILE WE CAN WILL YOU
GO AHEAD AND OPEN ROLE ON A
NUMBER OF ITEMS- SO THAT SENATOR
GROWTH CAN ADD ON. AND LET'S SEE
ITEM- R. TWO F. APPOINTEE NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR. A STEVEN FOR
NOW LEAVE MEMBER OF THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD-
CALL THE RULES. GROUP I GREW BY.
ZERO FIVE ZERO THANK YOU SO MUCH
COLLEAGUES AND THEN ON ITEMS
THREE FOUR AND FIVE BILL
REFERRALS AND TO FLOOR IT
KNOWLEDGE MINTS WILL YOU OPEN
THE ROLE. GROUP I GROUP II FIVE
ZERO FIVE ZERO THANK YOU SO
MUCH- WITH THAT- I THINK WE'LL
GO AHEAD TO THE NEXT
APPOINTMENT. THAT WOULD BE ITEM
ONE B. UNDER GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
THE APPOINTMENT OF TINA R.
JOHNSON HALL AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF OUR CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY. LET ME
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. LET
ME WELCOME YOU AND GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE ANYONE
YOU WOULD LIKE WHO MIGHT BE WITH
YOU OR- ANYONE YOU LIKE TO THE
KNOWLEDGE. OPENING COMMENTS AND
THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT TO OUR
CAUGHT MY COLLEAGUES FOR
QUESTIONS. ANNA AND COMMENTS
WELCOME. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY. I JUST WANT
TO SHARE THAT FOR THE PAST
THIRTY YEARS I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE TO WORK IN DIFFERENT
SECTORS OF THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COMMUNITY THAT I BELIEVE
IS ALTOGETHER PREPARED ME TO
LEAD CALAFATE. SO I'M VERY
GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR FOR
THIS APPOINTMENT. EARLY IN MY
CAREER I WORKED FOR AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER AND
IN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. BEFORE
JOINING THE WHAT BANKING WORLD
WHERE I GAINED EXPERTISE IN
FINANCING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND- COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND
THEN I USE THAT TO EXECUTE
MISSION AND PROFIT DRIVEN
TRANSACTION. WHILE THERE I ALSO
SPENT TIME SERVING ON BOARDS AND
VARIOUS ADVISORY COMMITTEES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS.
AND THIS ALLOWED ME TO SORT OF
PEEK INTO THE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND WORK AND LEARN SOME OF
THE BEST MODELS OF BALANCING
MISSION PROFITABILITY. MY MOST
FORMATIVE AND RELEVANT
EXPERIENCE WITH THE LAST SEVEN
YEARS WHICH LED UP TO THIS
APPOINTMENT. WHERE I.
SIMULTANEOUSLY SERVED ON CALLAGY
BASED BOARD OF DIRECTORS WHILE
TAKING ON THE ROLE OF CREATING
DESIGNING AND IMPLEMENTING A
NATIONAL FINANCING PLATFORM FOR
CEDIA FIVE AMONG OTHER THINGS.
MY WORK SB EVA AND CALAFATE WAS
FOCUSED ON THE INTERSECTIONS OF
FINANCING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. AND PAR FOR THE
COURSE THAT MEANT WE NEEDED TO
HAVE SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTISE WE
NEED TO BE PRAGMATIC WE NEED TO
HAVE A VISION AND WE NEED TO
MOVE QUICKLY. WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHERE I FEET CALAVERAS
CONTRIBUTION WITHIN THE BROADER
HOUSING ECO SYSTEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AT ITS CORE CALAFATE
ISN'T ORGANIZATION THAT THRIVES
ON LEVERAGING PARTNERSHIPS. WE
WILL NEED TO LEAN IN IN ORDER TO
SUCCESSFULLY SUCCESSFULLY
LAUNCHED NEW PROGRAMS. BUT ALSO
STAY ON THE CUTTING EDGE OF NEW
PRODUCT DELIVERY TOOLS FOR NEW
AND EXISTING HOMEOWNERS. AS WELL
AS FOR THE PRODUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING. AS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR I INTEND TO
IDENTIFY WHAT I CALL THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHITE SPACE.
THAT IS THE PLACES WHERE WE KNOW
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS BUT WE HAVEN'T YET
FOUND SOLUTION. SO WE WILL BE
EXPANDING THE AGENCY'S FOCUS ON
DELIVERING FINANCING SOLUTIONS
IN AN EQUITABLE WAY WITH A FRESH
SET OF EYES TO INCREASE
EFFICIENCY THROUGHOUT THE
AGENCY. AND I TOLD MY TEAM. IF
WE THINK IT'S HARD DON'T BE
AFRAID TO GO THERE. BECAUSE I
UNDERSTAND FIRSTHAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF WHAT WE DO AND HOW
IT CAN CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY OF
THE POOR AND WORKING. AND
UNDERSERVED AND NEGLECTED
COMMUNITIES. HARD IS WHAT THEY
HAVE TO IN TO WORK EVERY DAY. I
KNOW A LITTLE SOMETHING ABOUT
THAT LIFE BECAUSE I WAS THAT
TWENTY SOMETHING SINGLE MOM WITH
TWO KIDS WHO FOUND SAFETY AND
SECURITY IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. I WAS ALSO THE
FIRST TIME HOME BUYER WHO USED
HOMEOWNERSHIP PROGRAMS THE
PURCHASE MY FIRST HOME WHICH
ULTIMATELY LED TO A PROSPEROUS
LIFE FOR MY KIDS. AND WEALTH
CREATION THAT WILL NOW BE ABLE
TO BE PASSED ON TO MY GRANDKIDS
. NOT ONLY DO THESE EXPERIENCES
DRIVE ME BUT IT CENTERS ME. AND
IT GIVES ME THE INSIDER
KNOWLEDGE THAT MANY IN SIMILAR
POSITIONS JUST ON HALF. I INTEND
TO USE THAT EXPERIENCE LEGALITY
OF FAITH WE CONTINUE TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS FIND SAFE DIGNIFIED
AND STABLE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SOLUTIONS. IN LATITUDE JOB
CALAFATE HAS AN AMAZING
FRAMEWORK TO HELP THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS OUT THERE WITH
SIMILAR STORIES JUST LIKE MINE.
AND NOW IT'S MY TIME. SO I ALONG
WITH THE REST OF MY TEAM WILL BE
INVESTING IN DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
THE FINANCING PROGRAMS THAT HELP
MORE CALIFORNIANS. A PLACE TO
CALL HOME. I WANT CLOSE JUST BY
THINKING THAT STAFF THAT
WONDERFUL STAFF THAT HELPED ME
TO PREPARE FOR THE DAY. ALSO THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS. SECRETARY
LOTUS CASTRO IN B. C. EIGHTEEN
AND A THREE PM OTHER PARTNERS.
FOUNDED IN THEIR HEARTS TO MAKE
THIS ROLE IN EASE ME INTO MY
FIRST EIGHT MONTHS. ALSO WANT TO
THANK ITS KNOWLEDGE THOSE FOLKS
IN THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INDUSTRY WILL PERSONALLY REACHED
OUT TO ME TO CHEER ME ON. AND OF
COURSE I WANT TO THANK MY
FAMILY. MY FRIENDS WHO HAVE
SUPPORTED ME AONG THE WAY THAT
INCLUDES MY HUSBAND MARIO HOLE.
MY CHILDREN ROSS. HEART IN
KAELIN WILSON AND THEIR
PERSPECTIVE PARDON SHE NAY AND
DOMINATE. WE'RE ON THE PHONE
TODAY LISTENING. THANKYOU. FOR
EVERYTHING THAT YOU DO. AND NOW
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT MANY MEMBERS WE
HAVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH I
APPRECIATE THOSE OPENING
COMMENTS- VERY MUCH. US SENATOR
GROWTH IS GOING TO GO FIRST AND-HE MAY HAVE TO RUN BACK OUT TO
HEALTH GO RIGHT AHEAD THANK YOU
MADAM FOR TIM. AND THANK YOU
MISTER JOHNSON HOW FOR YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT YOUR HEART IN
YOUR PASSION FOR- THE AMERICAN
DREAM HOME WHEN I'M HOME
OWNERSHIP IN A PLACE TO LIVE ARE
TRULY EVIDENT IN NOT ONLY THE
JOB. THAT YOU HAVE HAD JOBS THAT
YOU HAVE HAD IN THE PAST IN AND
WHERE YOU WILL GO AFTER THIS
CONFIRMATION SO THANK YOU. I DO
APOLOGIZE AGAIN I HAVE TO BOUNCE
BACK TO HAVE ANOTHER COMMITTEE
SO I APPRECIATE THE PRO TEN
LETTING ME GO FIRST I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. AND A FEW
JUST TO A WHAT'S CAL HATER IS IN
V. BARRIERS TO HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION IN SPRING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
IN CALIFORNIA. AND THERE'S
SEVERAL. PIECES OF LEGISLATION
THAT IF PASSED THE YEARS SEEK
WERE- YOU KNOW YOU HAVE SOME
AREAS WHERE YOU REALLY NEED TO
BUILD IN THEM. YOU KNOW IT'S
POLICY AREAS IN YOU MIGHT HAVE
NIMBYISM. LOCAL ORDINANCES
THINGS LIKE THAT IT. WOULD CAN
YOU IDENTIFY THOSE BARRIERS AND
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO TO MAKE
SURE THOSE BARRIERS. OF LIMITED
OR DON'T EXIST SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. ES THANK YOU. I THINK
THE LARGEST BARRIER THAT WE HAVE
TO TACKLE IS THE OVERALL PROBLEM
WITH HOUSING SUPPLY- AND THIS IS
GOING TO REQUIRE A MULTIFACETED
APPROACH ALL ALL OF THE HOUSING
AGENCIES ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
COME TOGETHER TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO FOCUS ON THE LAND USE AND
REGULATORY REFORMS AND SEEK WAYS
TO STREAMLINE PRODUCTION AND
PROVIDE DEVELOPMENT IMPACT
PERHAPS THE MOST. WHICH I
BELIEVE IS PERHAPS THE MOST
IMPORTANT PIECE. WE'RE VERY
FORTUNATE THAT. SOME OF YOU ALL
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN RECENT
LEGISLATIVE MEASURES SUCH AS S.
NINE ESCAPED. SB THREE THIRTY.
WHICH I BELIEVE WILL BE CRITICAL
TO THIS EFFORT. AND I ALSO WANT
TO COMMEND THE WORK THAT OUR
COLLEAGUES AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EACH CD HAVE BEEN ENGAGED IN. IN
DOING SORT OF FURTHERING THE
STATE'S EFFORTS TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- AS WELL AS
INCREASE LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY
AND PROVIDING REGULATORY
CERTAINTY IN THE MARKET WHICH I
THINK WILL BE KEY TO BUT TO
FURTHERING OF PRODUCTION EFFORTS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT AND I APPRECIATE THAT
COMMENT BECAUSE I DID HAVE THREE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAD ELIMINATED
ONE BECAUSE I DO NEED TO GO BACK
AND THAT WAS ABOUT YOUR
COLLABORATION WITH OTHER
AGENCIES A TOP OF. YOU KNOW THE
TOP. KEY FOR AGENCIES THAT YOU
WOULD WORK WITHIN COLLABORATION
SO I APPRECIATE THAT YOU ARE. A
LEADER THAT IS GOING TO
COLLABORATE WITH THOSE ADDRESS
OTHER AGENCIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE HOUSING WHAT'S YOUR
ESTIMATION OF THE HOUSING THAT
IS NEEDED- TO BE PRODUCED IN
CALIFORNIA IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
THE STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS. A
LOT OF THAT WORK IS BEING DONE
BY OUR PARTNERS IN FACT WITH
EIGHT CD AND WHAT THEY'RE
ESTIMATING TODAY IS THAT WE NEED
ABOUT TWO. POINT FIVE MILLION
HOUSING UNITS IN ORDER TO MEET
THE CURRENT NEEDS. THAT'S
SIGNIFICANT- BECAUSE A MILLION
OF THOSE ARE VULNERABLE
POPULATION. SO COLLABORATION IS
GOING TO BE ONE WAY THAT WE CAN
TACKLE THIS ISSUE BEST. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING FOR MANY YEARS WITH
THE FOR HOUSING AGENCIES ONE
EXAMPLE OF ONE JUST SIMPLE THING
THAT WE DID- WITH THE BOND
PROCESS WAS WORK WITH THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE TO DESIGN AN
APPLICATION THAT STREAMLINES AND
AVOIDS DUPLICATION OF EFFORT.
THAT MAKES THE PROCESS OVERALL
MORE COST EFFICIENT. AND COST
EFFECTIVE SO I THINK US
COLLABORATING IN FIGURE OUT WAYS
TO AVOID DUPLICATIVE EFFORTS AND
EFFICIENCIES FOR THE BORROWERS
WILL BE CONTENT WILL CONTINUE TO
BE THE WAY THAT WE MAKE STRIDES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
MA'AM THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WITH
YOUR BANKING HISTORY YOUR LOAN
HISTORY YOUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE FINANCE INDUSTRY AND ALSO
YOUR PASSION FOR- AND HEART TO
MAKE SURE THE AMERICAN DREAM
COMES TRUE IN IN HOMEOWNERSHIP
OR HOUSING. AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO VOTING FOR YOUR YOUR
CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU A CENTER
GROVE CENTER COME LONGER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO GO NEXT. SURE THANK
YOU. I AM. HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK WITH MR JOHNSON HALL
EARLIER TODAY M. AND X. M. AND
EXCITED TO SEE YOU AGAIN- I YOU
KNOW I'M GONNA JUST. NOT I DON'T
KNOW THAT EVERYONE WILL GET THIS
BUT I AM FEELING A BIT
CHARITABLE TODAY WITH MS JOHNSON
HALL BECAUSE SHE OUT NOT ONLY
GRADUATED FROM AN H. B. C. U.
BUT SHE IS ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
DIVINE NINE SO THEY'RE NINE
AFRICAN AMERICAN SORORITIES. AND
FRATERNITIES OF COURSE SHE'S NOT
IN MINE I WHICH IS WHY I AM
FEELING TERRIBLE ENOUGH TO GIVE
HER A SHOUT OUT- FOR BEING IN
ONE OF THE OTHERS- BUT
ULTIMATELY AT THE END OF THE DAY
THEY'RE ALL IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THEY FOCUS ON SERVICE. AND MS
JOHNSON HOW YOU SEEM TO BE
COMMITTED ADD TO THAT AS WELL. I
JUST HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
I ARE YOU KNOW WAS JAZZED
LISTENING TO ALL OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT- ARE COMING
OUT OF THE DEPARTMENT. AND WOULD
LOVE TO KNOW SOME IDEAS THAT YOU
HAVE ABOUT MORE CREATIVE WAYS.
THAT- CAL HFA. CAN SUPPORT THE
INCREASE OF ACCESSIBLE-
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUPPLY YOU
TALKED ABOUT. WHAT'S NEEDED ARE
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF REGULATION
IN TERMS OF INCREASED
COLLABORATION IN TERMS OF
STREAMLINING PRODUCTION ARE
THERE OTHER SORT OF YOU KNOW OUT
OF THE BOX. INNOVATIONS THAT ARE
MAY BE HAPPENING IN OTHER STATES
. OR WE COULD SORT OF TEST CASE
HERE BECAUSE WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE-
CITIES WHERE THE COST OF LIVING
IS INCREDIBLY HIGH AND THE
SUPPLY OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS
INCREDIBLY LOW- AND SO THINGS
THAT HAVE BEEN WORKING IT'S
IMPORTANT TO DOUBLE DOWN ON
THOSE BUT I TINK WE'RE ALWAYS
EXCITED TO HEAR ABOUT NEW
INNOVATIONS. AND POSSIBILITIES-
THAT WE COULD ALSO IMPLEMENT. TO
HELP US ATTACKERS SUPPLY ISSUED
A SUPPLY PROBLEM. THANK YOU
SENATOR KAMLAGER I WOULD SAY
THAT THE OUR ANSWER TO THE
SUPPLY ISSUE IS A PROGRAM THAT
WE LAUNCHED BACK IN DECEMBER AND
IT IS THE ACCESSORY DWELLING
UNIT PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM
PROVIDES GRANTS OF UP TO FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO EXISTING
HOMEOWNERS WHO FILLED AN EIGHTY
YEAR ON THEIR PROPERTY. THE
GRANT CAN BE USED FOR PRE
DEVELOPMENT COSTS PLANS AND SO
FORTH. AND WE OF ALLOCATED ABOUT
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO GET
THIS PROGRAM OFF THE GROUND. IF
YOU LOOK AT WHERE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS GONE OVER THE
PAST YEAR YOU'LL NOTE THAT THERE
IS A SIGNIFICANT THERE'S BEEN A
GROWTH IN INTEREST IN THIS AND
I'M HOPING THAT THIS IS ONE OF
THE PRODUCTS THAT WILL BE ABLE
TO. LEVERAGE IN A VERY LARGE WAY
OVER THE COMING YEARS. I ALSO
WANT TO TALK ABOUT ONE PROGRAM
THAT I AM PARTICULARLY EXCITED
ABOUT IT'S CALLED THE FORGIVABLE
EQUITY BUILDER PROGRAM. WITH
THIS PROGRAM WE'RE WE WILL BE
PROVIDING UP 210% OF THE
PURCHASE PRICE- AS A DP A LOAN.
FOR THAT BECOMES FORGIVABLE
AFTER FIVE YEARS THIS IS A
PROGRAM FOR FOLKS THAT ARE AT
80% A. EMMA- AND WHAT I LOVE
ABOUT THIS PROGRAM IS THAT IT
ALSO TOUCHES SOME OF THE
INEQUITIES THAT. AND THEN ALSO
BUT ALSO HELPS WITH
INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH FOR
FOLKS THAT HAVE BEEN
SYSTEMATICALLY AS WELL AS
LEGALLY- DISENFRANCHISED BY OUR
HOUSING MARKET. SO THIS IS ONE
THAT I CALLED THE GAME CHANGER.
AND I HOPE THAT FOLKS WILL GET
EXCITED ABOUT THIS IN SHARE IN
THE M. MESSAGING AROUND THIS
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO DO
SO MUCH THE TURN AROUND SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'VE HAD IN
CALIFORNIA. NOW MS JOHNSON HOW I
TOLD YOU THAT I DIDN'T WANT YOU
TALKING ABOUT THAT IN THE
HEARING BECAUSE I WANTED TO TRY
TO GET ALL OF THAT MONEY IN MY
DISTRICT. I'M SORRY YOUR MY
GOODNESS MY GOODNESS I'M- SAY
THAT- THE MIX INCOME PROGRAM IS
OVERSUBSCRIBED- AT EACH
APPLICATION CYCLES SO THAT ALSO
SUGGESTS THAT WE SHOULD BE
TRYING TO FIND MORE
OPPORTUNITIES- TO FUND THAT
BECAUSE IT IT THAT SEEMS TO BE
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL YES. YES
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT AND WE
ACTUALLY ACTUALLY HAVE AN
ALTERNATIVE CALL IN AN
ALTERNATIVE TO THAT. YOU'RE
RIGHT THE BOND PROGRAM IS REALLY
QUITE OVERSUBSCRIBED BUT WE
INTRODUCED LAST YEAR A RECYCLED
BOND PROGRAM. IT'S A LITTLE
COMPLICATED BUT EFFECTIVELY WHAT
IT DOES IS IT ALLOWS THE
TRANSFER OF TAX EXEMPT BONDS OF
THE TAX EXEMPT BOND AUTHORITY TO
OTHER PROJECTS. SO THE IMPORTANT
PART ABOUT THIS THE POOR NOTE
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM IS
THAT IT DOES NOT GO AFTER
EXISTING BOND ALLOCATION OR TAX
CREDITS IT'S A IT'S KIND OF A GO
AROUND. AND SO THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT WE HAVE ACTUALLY SIGNED AN
MOU WITH THE SAN DIEGO AS WELL
AS OAKLAND. AND SO FAR AND WE
THINK THAT BY AT THE END OF THE
DAY WILL BE ABLE TO PRODUCE
SOMEWHERE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
THREE THOUSAND UNITS OUTSIDE OUR
ALREADY OVERTAXED SYSTEM. SO WE
HAVE A PLAN TO GET THIS OUT TO
AS MANY CITIES THAT CAN WHO HAVE
EXISTING. FOR ISSUERS OF BONDS
AND HAVE EXISTING PORTFOLIOS
WHERE WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO FIND-
SOME TRANSACTIONS. TO FACILITATE
THIS PROGRAM. GREAT THANK YOU
FOR THAT NOW ARE YOU GOING TO
ARE ALL THESE EIGHT K. IS GOING
TO CALL IN AND SUPPORT. OINTMENT. OF SENATOR I HOPE SO BUT I
HAVE TO TELL YOU. I HAVE A AWFUL
LOT OF THAT IS IN MY FAMILY.
WELL THEY'RE ALL MY ON. SO THEY
WERE A LITTLE BIT UPSET WITH ME
WHEN I WENT BACK IN THAT
DIRECTION. I DO HOPE THAT MY
SORORITY SISTERS WILL CALL INTO
SUPPORT THANK YOU WELL I THEY
SHOULD- AND IT ALSO THAT
RESPONSE LETS ME KNOW HOW YOU
HAVE DONE YOUR THOROUGH HOMEWORK
SO. THANK YOU FOR THAT- I LOOK
FORWARD TO. BEING ABLE TO
SUPPORT YOUR CONFIRMATION AND AS
WE DISCUSSED I LOOK FORWARD TO
BEING ABLE TO PARTNER WITH YOUR
AGENCY I THINK THIS WORK IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND THE
INFORMATION- THAT IS AVAILABLE
THROUGH YOU ALL AND THE PROGRAMS
THAT YOU ARE OFF. PROBABLY MORE
CRITICAL- THAN EVER BEFORE AND
SO YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT THAT
WE WILL BE PARTNERING ON SOME
WAYS TO OUT REACH TO-
COMMUNITIES AND NEIGHBORHOODS IN
MY DISTRICT TO GET THIS
INFORMATION OUT SO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR SERVICE. THANK YOU
SENATOR COM LONGER- SENATOR
MADAM VICE CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GO NEXT. LET JOHN GO JOHN
JOHN IS HAVING TO ASK QUESTIONS
. DID I DID I SKIP YOU DON'T
WANT TO. GOOD THANK YOU THAT
THEY KEEP ME THEY KEEP ME ON
YOUR TEST CALL JOHN JOHNSON HALL
THEY KEEP ME ON MY TOES MA'AM I
SURE GO RIGHT AHEAD THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND THANK YOU- THIS IS
JOHNSON HALL DIRECTOR OF I WAS
ALREADY PLANNING ON VOTING FOR
YOU JUST READING THE BACKGROUND
REMEMBERING OUR INTERACTION WHEN
YOU'RE APPOINTED TO THE BOARD AS
A BOARD MEMBER I BELIEVE IN
TWENTY TWENTY BUT CHAO YEAR
INTRODUCTORY STATEMENTS TODAY
JUST SEAL THE DEAL- YOUR YOUR
DISCUSSION ABOUT SOME OF THE
INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH IN THE
ABILITY TO. YOU KNOW- GROW THAT
WITHIN OUR FAMILIES IS SO VERY
IMPORTANT CERTAINLY IS THE
BACKGROUND FOR MY FAMILY WHERE
MY POOR MOM HAD TO LEAVE SCHOOL
WHEN SHE WAS MERELY FOURTEEN
BECAUSE THEY WERE STARVING IN
THOSE DAYS SO- BUT THE ABILITY.
TO ACQUIRE PROPERTY AND- THE OUT
YOU KNOW PASS THAT THE IT WAS
CERTAINLY AWARE THAT THEY WERE
ABLE TO MAKE THEIR WAY BACK. SO
THAT SIDE CRITICAL AYE-
MENTIONED ONLY AND IN TERMS OF
DISAPPOINTMENT WITH THE MEASURE
THAT WAS ON THE BALLOT THAT WILL
PROBABLY ENTER PARA. INTERCEPTOR
IMPACT ON THEIR ABILITY GOING
FORWARD AND I'M I'M SURE YOU'RE
GOING TO FOCUS SOME OF YOUR
EFFORTS ON BALLOT. IN THE IN THE
COMING YEARS I DO HAVE ONE QUICK
QUESTION. REGARDING THE MIXED
INCOME PROGRAM FINANCE PROJECTS
ARE THAT SEEM TO BE ABLE TO
REACH CONSTRUCTION QUICKER. AND
FOR LESS THAN OTHER COMPARABLE
DEVELOPMENTS THAT WAS IN THE
BACKGROUND INFORMATION- IS THAT
ACCURATE AND- IF SO- WHAT MIGHT
BE OF THE REASONS FOR THAT AND
SOMETHING MAYBE WE NEED TO BUILD
ON. THANK YOU SENATOR- THAT IS
ACCURATE- EVEN TODAY- THAT
PROGRAM WAS VERY SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED FOR COST EFFICIENCY AND
FOR THE ABILITY TO BRING
TRANSACTION TO FRUITION. AND THE
OTHER QUICK REMOTE MORE AND IN A
IN A IN A FAST WAY- WHAT WE HAVE
NOTICED BECAUSE OF THE SUPPLY
ISSUES IS THAT IT'S A LITTLE BIT
SLOWER BUT STILL. QUICKER THAN
WHAT YOU WOULD GENERALLY SEE
WITH THE TWO OTHER- FINANCING
CHANNELS- AND SO I BELIEVE THAT
EVEN TODAY- THE PROGRAM WHAT WE
WILL SEE. IS THAT THOSE PROGRAMS
WILL BE COMING TO FRUITION IN
JUST A FEW YEARS WILL HAVE THOSE
PROJECTS ACTUALLY ALBUM
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC SO THAT
THEY COULD MOVE IN. I THINK WHAT
HAS MADE IT MEMORABLE AND IS
ACTUALLY THE TERMS OF THE OF THE
PROGRAM ITSELF- AND THE FACT
THAT WITH THE PROGRAM WE ARE
PROVIDED FINANCING WE ARE ALSO.
PROVIDED WITH BONDS AND JUST
THOSE TWO SOURCES ARE OFTEN JUST
OF SUFFICIENT ENOUGH TO MOVE THE
PROCESS THROUGH QUICKLY.
OFTENTIMES AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR REQUIRES UP MULTIPLE CAPITAL
SEOUL SOURCES SOMETIMES FIVE
FIVE SIX SEVEN SOURCES AND SO
THAT IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
OUR PROGRAM MOVES. HIM TO MOVE
QUICKER. THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
CERTAINLY YOU HAVE MY ON. MY
VOTE FOR YOUR CONFIRMATION AND-
I DO THAT AS HIGH FIVE TO YOU
AND YOUR PASSION FOR THIS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT ROLE THAT YOU
HAVE TAKEN ON SO THANK YOU FOR
DOING THAT AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
BEING ABLE TO VOTE FOR YOU FOR
THE CONFIRMATION. THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR SENATOR LAYERED
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. N. P.
ANNOUNCER JUST FOLLOWING ALONG
EVERYBODY ELSE ALTHOUGH I
CLEARLY DO NOT HAVE A SORORITY
CONNECTION- THE YOU WERE VERY
ELOQUENT IT IN YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT THEN IF YOU BRING
UNIQUE QUALIFICATIONS WHETHER
WONDERING WHETHER IT'S WORTH
HOUSING AGENCIES OR WHETHER IT'S
WITH GOVERNMENT AGENCIES THEN
YOU WERE REALLY ELOQUENT ABOUT
YOUR OWN STORY. I THINK THE YOU
KNOW ONE OF THE TWO QUESTIONS I
HAVE IS YOU ARE HEADING AN
AGENCY THAT HAS PROGRAMS THAT
ARE PRESCRIBED THEY REALLY THEY
HAVE RULES THERE ARE CERTAIN
WAYS YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
IMPLEMENT THEM OR ACT ON THEM
HOW DO YOU TAKE THE COMMITMENT
THAT YOU DEMONSTRATED IN YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT AND YOUR
EXPERIENCE. MAKE PROGRAMS MIGHT
BE VERY PRESCRIBED WORK IN THE
WAY THAT YOUR VALUES TELL YOU
THEY SHOULD WORK- VERY GOOD
QUESTION SENATOR THANK YOU FOR
IT. I THINK THE WAY THAT I LOOK
AT THIS IS THAT OUR PRODUCTS
NEED TO BE AS DIVERSE AS OUR
HOUSING. AND SO ONE WAY TO
TACKLE THAT IS TO COME UP WITH
DIFFERENT PRODUCTS. ON TO
ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS. AND SO ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I TALK ABOUT
THAT WHITE SPACE IN AND LOOKING
AT WAYS THAT WE COULD ACTUALLY
BE A LITTLE BIT MORE INNOVATIVE
IN THE WAY THAT WE HAVE WORKED
GOING FORWARD. SO I THINK THE
WAY THAT YOU ANSWER THAT
QUESTION IS THAT THE WAY TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION BEST IN A
WAY TO WORK WITHIN THOSE.
PRESCRIBED BEST IS TO COME UP
WITH AS MANY PRODUCTS AS WE CAN
DELIVER WITH THE RESOURCES THAT
WE HAVE. THE THAT'S PART OF MY
PLAN. I'VE GOT- SEVERAL SEVERAL
THINGS IN MY BACK POCKET THAT I
HAVE FOOLED. FROM MY BANKING
EXPERIENCE AND ALSO MINDS
EXPERIENCE NOT ONLY WORKING IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
WORKING NATIONALLY. AND SO
THAT'S- THAT'S THAT'S WHAT'S
GOING TO MAKE THE DIFFERENCE. IN
IS COMING UP WITH AS MANY
PRODUCTS AS BEFORE. MAN IN THAT
PROCESS IF. YOU FIGURE OUT THAT
THERE'S SOME WAYS THAT THE
PROGRAMS COULD BE STRUCTURED
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENTLY. IS THAT
SOMETHING WHERE WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM YOU WHERE ARE WILL
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION AND
IF YOU THINK THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT COULD BE DONE. THAT BETTER
MEETS THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE. ELIGIBLE FOR YOUR PRODUCTS
THAT YOU WILL. COMMUNICATE WITH
US. ABSOLUTELY WE WILL
COMMUNICATE WITH YOU. I WILL SAY
THIS AS WELL SENATOR. THAT WHILE
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT A LOT OF OUR
PRODUCTS ARE PRESCRIBED NOT JUST
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL BUT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WE ARE SEEING
WE'RE STARTING TO SEE FOLKS
LISTEN A LOT MORE- THEY WANT
THESE PROGRAMS TO WORK AS- BEST
AS THEY CAN. AND SO WE HAVE NOT
BEEN SHY ABOUT USING OUR NETWORK
TO CHALLENGE THOSE
PRESCRIPTIONS. AND WELL YOU KNOW
IT'S GOING TO BE AT THE END OF
THE DAY IT'S GOING TO BE UP TO
THEM TO HELP WITH THAT. BUT THEY
OPEN ABOUT TAKING A LOOK AT
THINGS BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE ALL
INTERESTED AT THIS POINT IN.
HELPING PEOPLE GET HEALTH AS A
PRIORITY. SO THERE'S FLEXIBILITY
IN THE MARKET. NOT A LOT OF
FLEXIBILITY BUT AT LEAST FOLKS
ARE REALLY WILLING. TO RETHINK
IT AND ASK THEMSELVES IF
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY. YOU KNOW.
SO IF THOSE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THE LEGISLATURE LIKE YOURSELF
THEN YOU ALL HELPING US TO MAKE.
THAT CASE AND TELL THAT STORY
THAT I THINK IS GOING TO HELP
GOING FORWARD. OKAY WELL I WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. RESPONSE
AND I HOPE WE DO IT AND HE HAD A
SMILE ON HOPE AND MY SPOUSE WAS
NOT WATCHING BECAUSE WE'RE ABOUT
THREE QUARTERS OF THE WAY
THROUGH THE CONSTRUCTION OF AN
EIGHTY YOU. THE LAST THING I
WOULD HAVE NEEDED IS FOR HIM TO
THINK WE COULD APPLY FOR
ANYTHING. BUT THE- BUT I'VE
LEARNED A LOT FROM THAT HE SAID
THAT I HOPE REFLECTS INTO THE
SYSTEM. AND I JUST HOPE WE WOULD
CONTINUE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
BECAUSE I THINK. THAT THE WORLD
IS CHANGING AND SO MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS THE LEVEL OF
AFFORDABILITY. OF THE NUMBER OF
HOMELESS PEOPLE IN THE WAY THAT
SOME NEEDS COME OUT OF THAT ARE
THINK WE'D REALLY LIKE TO. WORK
TOGETHER BECAUSE YOU CITED THE
AUTHOR OF ONE OF THE TWO BILLS
YOU SITE I SITTING TO THE SIDE
HERE. AND WE ARE WORKING HARD TO
RESPOND SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO SERVE AND BRING
SUCH GREAT EXPERIENCE AND BRING
THE PASSION I LOOK FORWARD TO.
SUPPORTING YOU WHEN WE GET TO A
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED
AND- I AT THAT BIRD THAT BRINGS
IT TO ME AND I COULDN'T BE MORE
THRILLED ABOUT THIS CONFIRMATION
OF THIS APPOINTMENT- EKING ALONG
THE SAME LINES AS A NUMBER OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND FOR SENATOR
LAYERED TO RECOGNIZE YOUR
RESUME. AND THE DIVERSITY OF
THAT RESUME THAT HELPS TO BE
PREPARED TO LOOK AT HOW WE
PROVIDE HOUSING IN THE STATE- IT
YOU KNOW IT YOU'RE YOU'RE THE
PERFECT PERSON TO DO THIS JOB.
ARIENS TO YOUR PROFESSIONAL WORK
LIFE AND FROM THE REPUTATION
THAT YOU HAVE IN THE STATE.
WHICH IS WHAT LED TO ADD TO IT
AS THE VICE CHAIR SAID TO I
THINK THE GOVERNOR APPOINTING
YOU TO THE BOARD. AND THEN
RECOGNIZING THAT YOU WOULD BE
THE PERFECT PERSON TO LEAD THIS
AGENCY- THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST
SERIOUS ISSUES IN OUR STATE IN
TERMS OF OUR ECONOMIC VIABILITY
IN TERMS OF- THE STABILITY OF
FAMILIES AND- I THINK. WE HAVE
COME UP WITH SOME INTERESTING
AND CREATIVE TOOLS. OF A
FINANCING IS SO COMPLICATED FOR
DEVELOPMENTS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND SO. YOU KNOW THAT
INTIMATELY AND I THINK USING
YOUR STAFF AND YOUR BOARD. AS
INCREDIBLE RESOURCES TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO MAKE IT BETTER. I
APPRECIATE I DID WANT TO ASK A
QUESTION AND CENTER LAYERED I
HOPE MY SPOUSE ISN'T LISTENING
EITHER BECAUSE SHE'S. SHE IS
GETTING READY TO AND TO
UNDERTAKEN A D. U. AS WELL HAHA
I SAY SHE BECAUSE SHE WILL NOT
ALLOW ME TO HAVE ANY INPUT INTO
THIS PROCESS. SHE SHE WILL ACT
LIKE SHE WILL LET ME AND THEN IT
WILL TURN OUT THAT. IF I GET TO
PICK OUT THE DOOR KNOB I'LL BE
LUCKY- AND THAT'S ALL GOOD
FRANKLY I'LL BE CLEAR. BUT ON
THE A. D. U. R. PEAS I'M
INTERESTED TO HEAR HOW YOU THINK
IT'S GOING THROUGHOUT THE STATE
BECAUSE- I LOVE THE IDEA OF THAT
IS A PRODUCT FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO CREATE- THE ABILITY TO OWN A
HOME THEMSELVES TO USE AN ID YOU
EITHER FOR FAMILY. OR OR AS A
MEANS TO PAY THE MORTGAGE FOR
OWNING A HOME ALL OF THOSE
THINGS MAKE THIS A WONDERFUL.
OPPORTUNITY HOW ARE YOU SEE IN
THIS UNVEILED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE DO YOU HAVE. ANYTHING
YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE WITH US
ABOUT. CERTAIN AREAS ARE THEY
DOING IT BETTER THAN OTHER AREAS
HAVE YOU ENCOUNTERED RESISTANCE
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. I KNOW
SOME OF THEM BRACED IT OTHERS
MAY BE A LITTLE BIT SLOWER- AND
IT JUST JUST KIND OF A LITTLE
MORE IN DEPTH ABOUT ABOUT WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING IN RELATED TO THIS
PROGRAM AND OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
GRANTS FOR THOSE WHO. NEED THEM
TO MAKE THE A. D. USE A REALITY
. THANK YOU SENATOR. WELL ONE OF
THE KEY COMPONENTS OF OUR
PROGRAM IS OUR LINDER NETWORK IN
THAT'S ALSO THE KEY COMPONENT OF
BUILDING AN EIGHTEEN YEAR WITH
WELL- AND SO ONE OF THE-
CHALLENGES THAT WE DO SEE IS
THAT ARE THE LENDER NETWORK IN
THE FOLKS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
AB YOU DEVELOPMENT. IS NOT AS
ROBUST AS WE HAD INITIALLY
THOUGHT- THERE ARE CITIES THAT I
BELIEVE THAT ARE MORE ROBUST
THAN OTHERS IN IN TERMS OF
FINDING. A PARTNER AND A
CONSTRUCTION LENDER PARTNER TO
WORK WITH SACRAMENTO HAPPENS TO
BE ONE OF THEM. THEY'VE GOT SOME
GREAT PARTNERS THERE BUT WE'RE
WORKING VERY HARD TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF LENDERS WHO ARE
AVAILABLE TO HELP SUPPORT THIS
BUSINESS AS A PRIORITY. OF
COURSE WE ARE ALSO LOOKING AT
DEVELOPING- WOULD DEVELOPING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH NONTRADITIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS WITH CDFI
ORGANIZATION. YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT BOOTS ON THE GROUND
THEY'VE BEEN ON THE GROUND FOR A
VERY LONG TIME AND SO WE ARE
EXTENDING THE TYPES OF LENDERS
THAT WE ARE DOING WORK WITH SO
THAT WOULD INCLUDE CDFI. CREDIT
UNIONS AND THINGS LIKE THAT-
TEND TO BE ABLE TO BE A LITTLE
BIT MORE NIMBLE IN THE FACE- I
THINK WE ARE SEEING SOME ROBUST
ACTIVITIES IN CERTAIN CITIES I
MENTIONED SACRAMENTO WE ARE ALSO
SEEING IN SAN JOSE. ANOTHER AREA
ON AND SO WE THINK IN PART OF
THE REASON WHY WE INCREASED OUR
AMOUNTS TO FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IS THAT WE THINK THAT-
WITH OUR ADDITIONAL OUTREACH
RELATIVE TO MARKETING WHETHER
THAT BE ONLINE AND SO FORTH BOB
WILL BE SOME WAYS TO PICK UP ON
THIS ACTIVITY IN A BIG WAY. BUT
IT WILL BE CHALLENGING- PEOPLE
STILL ARE A LITTLE BIT I THINK
IN GENERAL FOLKS ARE A LITTLE
BIT CONCERNED ABOUT THE OVERALL
COST OF REAL. WHICH CAN BE OF
CONSIDERABLE. AND FOR SOME FOLKS
WHO WERE THE MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS IT MIGHT EVEN BE
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE AND DIFFICULT
GIVEN THE OVERALL COST METRIC
FOR THIS. SO WE'RE ALSO REACHING
OUT TO- PARTNERS CITIES WHO ARE
. NOT AFRAID TO DO THIS A SOME
OF THOSE INCLUDE THE CITY OF
PASADENA AS AN EXAMPLE AND WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO
LEVERAGE OUR DOLLARS WITH THEIR
DOLLARS TO HOPEFULLY MAKE THIS A
MORE PALATABLE- PROPOSITION FOR
THEM ESPECIALLY THOSE ON THE FAR
. THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF MY
STUFF WELL THANK YOU AND I HOPE-
TO THE COMMON AND ANOTHER OF MY
COLLEAGUES MADE IF YOU HAVE
IDEAS THAT. YOU THINK ARE WORTHY
OF CONSIDERATION THAT WOULD
REQUIRE- OUT LEGISLATION THAT
YOU WOULD LET US KNOW THERE'S NO
LACK OF I THINK LEGISLATORS WHO
WANT TO BE HELPFUL IN THIS ARENA
SO. THANK YOU FOR THAT WITH
THAT- I THINK WE CAN MOVE TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT-
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO THIS
CONFIRMATION. I WILL START RIGHT
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
AND SEE. IF THERE'S ANYONE FROM
THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE COME
ON FORWARD ON. TO THE PODIUM
HERE AND THE- STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND
COMMENTS. WELL GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE- PHIL
FUND AG FOUNDER AND CEO OF AGING
GLOBAL SOLUTIONS- I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF WORKING WITH MISS
JOHNSON ALL MY PREVIOUS CAPACITY
AS DEPUTY TREASURE FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- AND AS YOU ALL
KNOW JUST BY READING A RESUME
SHE'S MORE THAN X. ENOUGH
EXPERIENCE FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY-
WHAT I WANNA SPEAK TO IS REALLY
TWO FOLD. ONE IN MY CO PACKER
CAPACITY I REPRESENT DEVELOPER
CLIENTS BOTH NONPROFIT AND FOR
PROFIT. I'M ALSO EMERGING
DEVELOPER. AND WHAT I FOUND THAT
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT NOT
ONLY HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE THAT WE
SEE SHE HAS WHICH YOU COME TO
THE GREAT DEAL OF UNDERSTANDING.
OF THE INTERDEPENDENCE BETWEEN
DEVELOPERS. LABOR RESIDENTS AND
COMMUNITY THAT'S GOING TO BE
EXTREMELY POOR AS WE DEVELOP
POLICIES TO ENSURE THAT WE DON'T
INADVERTENTLY SUPPRESSED.
PRODUCTION SO WITH THAT I CREEK
DRIVE OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO. MUCH PLEASE COME
ON FORWARD. AND WELCOME. THANK
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CORNELIUS BURKE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR TINA JOHNSON HALL
SLOW CONFIRMATION IS EXPECTED
RIGHT FOR COLLEGE IF THEY- SHE
IS AMAZING ADVOCATE FOR HOUSING
SHE'S A TRUE HOUSING CHAMPION
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH HER A CBI SPROUT.
OR CONFIRMATION AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN IPHONE AND LAST I
JUST WANT TO SAY SIMPSON-
CALENDAR- WE ON THE STATE IS THE
BEST WAY OUT THERE ARE SO. MANY
WAYS. THAT THIS. THE SELF
EXPLANATORY. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
IF YOU'RE NOT UP WE SAID WE- WE
CERTAINLY LEARN A LOT ABOUT.
OURSELVES AS WELL AS AS WHAT
ENGAGES. OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY
HERE IN SACRAMENTO- WELL THANK
YOU- LET ME SEE- AT NO SEEING NO
ONE FURTHER- HERE PHYSICALLY IN
SUPPORT LET ME- GO BACK TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE- AND
MODERATOR A MONTH THROUGH THIS
NUMBER UP THERE AGAIN- EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE SIX THREE. ACCESS CODE.
SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX TWO
IF YOU WISH TO. SPEAK VIA
TELECONFERENCE AND LET ME
WELCOME BACK OUR MODERATOR TO
ASSIST US IN TEEING UP PEOPLE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF.
I MISS JOHNSON HALL. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR THE SONG PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE CHILD BY ZERO. IN SUPPORT WE
DO HAVE A FEW QUEUING UP ON THE
B. WITH THIS MOMENTARILY MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU THE OPERATOR.
WONDERFUL LIGHTING UP THE GROUP
. THANK YOU AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE ZERO SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO ME FAN ON
BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING IN
SUPPORT OF JOHNSON HALL
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT THE WITNESS. SIX WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE AWAIT YOU
ARE ALL COMPLETE CORRECT. HELLO
MY NAME IS DR MEGAN CURRY AND
JACK AND I HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
SERVING WAY. HE MATH- THROUGHOUT
OUR FACILITIES NEEDED WELL AS
YOU KILEY CROSSLAND BEIJING AND. I'M SURELY- THE FACT THAT SHE
IS EIGHT EDGED. MEMBER AND TO
OUR COMMUNITY AND ENSURING THAT.
NOTHING GOES WITHOUT A HE
CRAWLED ON A DIET A WEALTH OF
KNOWLEDGE AND RESEARCH TIME TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE CONTINUOUSLY
ON PUTTING OUR BEST FOOT
FORWARD. I KNOW THAT PASSED BY
WHICH HE HAD CALLED ME AND ALL.
I FIND ME. ARE YOU TRULY AS YOU
PASSION. AND THAT WOULD BE IN
HOUSE. DEDICATED HER TIME AND
KNOWLEDGE. ON THE WAVERING- ON
WAVERLY SO I CAN MANAGE THIS
AFTERNOON TRULY HELPFUL SUPPORT
IN THE WORK WHEN I KNOW TINA
DIED. WITHOUT AND FOR OUR
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU MUCH NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL
ALIGN WITH L. ONE OH NINE YOU
ARE OPEN ONE OR NINE. A YES-
ARTICLE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS STEVEN RUSSELL PRESIDENT
AND CEO OF SAN DIEGO HOUSING
FEDERATION BOARD MEMBER OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA MOST
IMPORTANTLY A BOARD MEMBER OF
CALLIE CAFE. I WAS HONORED TO
SERVE WITH HER AS A FELLOW BOARD
MEMBER DURING THE TIME THEY'RE
VERY PLEASED TO HAVE HER
LEADERSHIP- INDIANS PRESENT HI.
MY EXPERIENCE OF THE TEAM THAT
HAS BEEN THAT SHE IS REALLY
FOCUSED ON THE ON THE KEY ISSUES
OF OUR TIME BECAUSE HOW HOW THIS
HOUSING BUILD GENERATIONAL
WEALTH. MAKE UP FOR PAST
INEQUITIES I'VE BEEN DELIGHTED
WITH THE APARTMENT WITH HER IN
IN TRYING TO MAKE THAT A REALITY
SHE'S AN INCREDIBLE LEADER AND I
URGE. BOTH OF FOR CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH- NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
WILL ALLOW ONE OF. ONE OF FIVE
EUROPE IT. WELL YES YOU'RE WITH
US PLEASE GIVE US YOUR NAME-
ORGANIZATION AFFINITY AND YOUR-
TESTIMONY. HELLO MY NAME IS
KEVIN LOVE AND- I AM A MOTHER
FEELS AN AWFUL MEMBERS OF OUR-
GREAT. LAND THERE WHEN I AM ON
THE BALLOT BOX DOT- RIGHT NOW
YOU ARE. WORRIED ABOUT THIRTY
YEAR. WHEN HE VERY AND- LET ME
WHY HI ON FIVE. HOW WITHOUT
THOSE ME THAT OUR OF BY IF YOU
HAVE HOW YOU FIND NIGHT. I
THOUGHT I WOULD ON OTHER- HOW.
NOT THE CHARACTER. HE LAST FALL
WE WENT AT BUT SHE GOT VERY HOT
NET THANK GOD YOU VERY ANYWAY. I
H. HIGH DON'T ASK WORK
COMMUNITIES PARDON AND I'LL BE
BACK I DON'T AS THE LOT OF WORK
HOUSING AT A LITTLE IN THE
NINETEEN OCEAN PARK AND A LOT OF
AND DEATH PAIN. NO WAY HE DID IN
ORDER TO OUR HEALTH ABOUT. BUT I
OFFICE AFTER I THINK EVERY DAY.
ONE HARD LATE ONE THOUSAND NINE
EDUCATION WELL SEVERAL GETTING.
YEAH BUT NOT BEFORE THE- HE-
WELL MY WORK IN TO MAKE
STRANGERS A COMPUTER HOUSE AND
TO MAKE HAPPEN IN THE BOX. I
MIGHT ARE HI I'M OF HOW CAN HOW
. RIGHT NOW WELL I'M HERE FOR
MOMENT. I MOTHER YOU ON ONE ON
THE WAY AND ALLOW. OF MY HIGH
WELL WE SURE THAT THE OF
CALIFORNIA COULD NOT IN BETTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TEST- MISTER MOM NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. IF YOU MEDICARE
AND AS A REMINDER PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE SUPPORT AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE NOW ONE TEN
YOUR OPEN. CORRECT THIS MARCH
THAT EVERS CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIP AND WE HAVE A LONG
RELATIONSHIP WITH MR JOHNSON
HALL AND- THE CAMPUS FOR THE
CHOOSE LIKE. IN A TRUE- REALLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT THIS
COMPETITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER SERVERS A NEXT
WITNESS. IN ORDER PURCHASE WHICH
CUED UP THIS TIME THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE WILL BE BACK WITH YOU IN
JUST A MOMENT. I HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM THOSE WHO ARE I WISH TO
SPEAK IN AND SUPPORT WE WILL NOW
GO TO THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. I WILL START IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AND I SEE NO
ONE PHYSICALLY PRESENT-
APPROACHING THE DICE SO MISTER
MODERATOR I'M GONNA COME BACK TO
YOU AND SEE IF YOU COULD T. OF
FOLKS WHO WISH. NOT POSITION.
THANK YOU YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZEO. ONE STYLE BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MADAM CHAIR
NOBODY ELSE IS DOING UP. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE
WILL BE BACK WITH YOU IN A
LITTLE WHILE. AND I'M ONLY GLAD
THAT WE GOT NO CALL INS IN
OPPOSITION BASED ON YOUR
SORORITY STATUS- OBVIOUSLY IT
WAS A BIG ITEM FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT- THAT ARE. GOOD TO HAVE
A MOMENT OF LEVITY LET ME SEE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO ISSUE- YOU
SENATOR FROM WATER PLEASE. A
MOTION TO CONFIRM. I'M LONGER I
AM LONGER ARI LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES RIGHT THE AYE ATKINS AYE
AYE THIN SIDE FOREIGN CALL WE
WILL PUT THAT ON CALL SO THAT
SENATOR GROWTH CAN JOIN IN WHEN
SHE WERE FOR SOME HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND WITH THAT I WANT
TO SAY CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. I BUT- LEFT
YOU- AND WE- ALL YOU DO. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE THANK YOU-
WE WILL TAKE A FIVE MINUTE
BREAK- AND BE RIGHT BACK IN IN
ABOUT FIVE MINUTES THANK YOU.
ORDER GIVE EVERYONE A MINUTE TO
GET ADJUSTED. BEFORE WE GO TO
OUR- LAST SET OF APPOINTMENTS.
I WANT TO GIVE OUR APPOINTEES
TOM TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE BACK
AND READY THEY HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY PATIENT AS WE WORK
THROUGH TWO OTHER APPOINTMENTS.
OKAY GREAT I SEE THAT EVERYONE
IS READY SO WE WILL COME BACK TO
ORDER. AND- LET ME. WELCOME FOR
CONSIDERATION ARE ITEMS ONE C.
THROUGH E. UNDER GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
AND THESE APPOINTMENTS ARE
MEMBERS TO THE BOARD OF STATE
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS WE
HAVE MISS CYNTHIA M. SERVICE WE
HAVE MISTER KIRK HAINES AND
CHIEF ANDREW MILLS WITH US LET
ME SAY WELCOME TO EACH TO YOU
AND WE WILL START TO US SINCE
THERE ARE THREE ARM. MEMBERS TO
THIS BOARD OUR APPOINTMENTS WE
WILL LET EACH INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES ARE RECOGNIZED OR
THANK ANYONE THEY WOULD LIKE TO
AND THEN MAKE OPENING COMMENTS-
WE WILL START WITH MS SERVICE
AND THEN WE WILL GO TO MISTER
HAYNES WE WILL FINISH UP WITH
CHIEF MILLS- IN THAT ORDER AND
THEN WE'LL GO TO MY COLLEAGUES
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS THE
SERVICE LET ME WELCOME YOU AND
ASK YOU TO GO AHEAD AND START.
LIKE WITH THAT SAY WELCOME AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I AM SO GRATEFUL TO BE
WITH ALL OF YOU FOR THOSE OF YOU
I HAVEN'T MET MY NAME IS CINDY
CHAVEZ I'M A MEMBER OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. I HAVE SERVED ON BOARD
HERE SINCE TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
PRIOR TO THAT HE SERVED ON THE
SAN JOSE CITY COUNCIL THREE
YEARS AND WAS THE- EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF THE SOUTH BAY LABOR
COUNCIL AND I RAN A NONPROFIT
CALLED WORKING PARTNERSHIPS USA
. SINCE BEING ON THE- THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS. I HAVE
ESTABLISHED AND CO CHAIRED OUR-
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION ON JAIL
REFORMS. ARE BANNED ALL WORKING
AT A FEDERAL WORKING GROUP WHICH
IS LOOKING TO EDUCATE THE PUBLIC
ABOUT THE RISKS OF FINAL.
ARGUMENT TRAFFICKING COMMISSION.
OUR REENTRY THAT WORK. I AM SO
HONORED REALLY TO BE INVITED TO
SPEAK TO THAT. THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE AND JUST VERY GRATEFUL
TO THE GOVERNOR FOR CONSIDERING
ME FOR THIS APPOINTMENT. I'M
DELIGHTED AGAIN TO BE WITH ALL
OF YOU AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR QUESTION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
LET ME GO AHEAD AND WELCOME
MISTER HAYNES AND ASK YOU TO. DO
THE SAME WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANK YOU KNOW DEAR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY YOU'RE VERY CAREFUL
CONSIDERATION OF BEING COMPARED
TO THE BOARD THANK YOU CAN YOU
CORRECT. I LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU
TO MY WIFE GAINING HER CONTINUED
SUPPORT AS WELL AS GOVERNOR
HIMSELF BUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE THE DSCC. ARCHER
WINNIPEGGER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR KATHY HOWARD THEY'VE
BEEN IN THE SUPPORT BY POINTING
TO THE SEC I APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP. NOW DURING MY TWENTY
FROM EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT YEAR.
CAREER I ABOUT MY WAY UP A
VARIETY OF LEADERSHIP THE NOW
CHIEF OFFICER FRESNO COUNTY- I
WAS ALSO THERE ARE FACILITIES
DIRECTOR FOR ALMOST FOUR YEARS.
I'M AT THE DEPARTMENT AND DIET
IN THIS TWENTY EIGHT YEARS I
THINK TREMENDOUS CHANGE
INFORMATION PRACTICES WE WANT TO
BELIEVE THAT. WELCOME FOR. I THE
DEPARTMENT WITHIN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF CORRECTION
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN A BRIEF WHICH
WOULD HAVE SIX SEVENTY EIGHT.
AND ALSO A BIT OF EIGHTY ONE
FROM. A PRIME TENANT- THIS
REFLECT WITH THE OF THAT BASED
PRACTICE. IN THE KOBE WORK THAT
WE DO WHICH IS FOUNDATION TO THE
WORK WE DO FOR THAT. IM
COMMITTEE TO THE FOLLOWING
INTERVIEW IN THE IN A- GOOD
GRIEF. THE CURVE POSITIVE ON.
I'M THE- OVER THE LAST DECADE.
REDUCTIONS IN MARKETS YOUR
FAMILY YOUR TO THE OF LAWS YOUR
SUPPORT WHICH INCLUDE FROM
PRACTICE. I'M ALSO STRONGER FOR.
NEXT BE BACK IN THOSE NOT ONLY
IN YOUR- BUT ALSO UPSTREAM
ANOTHER CITIES OF WELL. THANK
YOU CAN READS OF THE SERVER
DELIVERY OF OUR- WHICH IS FUNDED
. I'M SORRY FUNDAMENTAL SOUND
CULTURE SENSITIVE EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICE THEM. PRESERVATION OF
THE B. S. WE WILL OR CALL FIVE
BURDENS EMERGENCY MERGING BEST
PRACTICE. THE SUPPORT ARE
REGULATED CAN. LAST THE
PERSPECTIVE THERE ARE BRING.
YES.
THANK YOU SENATOR ACT ATKINS
INITIALLY NICE TO SEE YOU AS THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AND TO- TELL YOU WHY
THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE
PART OF THE ORDER STATE
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS AS- ON A
REAL FINE. WE'RE ALSO GRATEFUL
TO GO SOME FOR THE- REDEPLOYMENT
TO DISPOSITION OR THAT THE
RECOMMENDATION AND AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. INTO REALLY HELPING TO
BRING A GREATER SENSE OF
JUSTICE. AND FAIRNESS INTO HOW
PEOPLE ARE INCARCERATED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ARE YOU
OVER FOUR DECADES OF POLICING
I'VE LEARNED A LOT- BOTH THE
HARD AND EASY WAY. AND IN I'VE
LEARNED THAT- PEOPLE ARE
REDEEMABLE AND- HAVING BEEN AN
ADVOCATE OF PROBLEM ORIENTED
POLICING AND FINDING OTHER
SOLUTIONS TO REDUCING CRIME AND
IMPROVING SAFETY IN BRINGING
JUSTICE FOR COMMUNITIES THIS IS
JUST AN EXTENSION. AN
OPPORTUNITY MR MORE. AND TO BE.
DEVELOP EVEN MORE MEETING AND
HOW WE LIVE OUR LIVES- TO
SERVICE SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY. SHOULD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE SERVED-
HOPEFULLY AGAIN AND ON THE ORDER
STATE COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF WHEN THE
FOUNDER. AND- WE REALLY ARE
GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF THAT- BSE
DOES FOR OUR COMMUNITY. AND OF
COURSE I WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE ALSO. WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M GOING TO
ASK MY COLLEAGUES AS YOU OF MAKE
COMMENTS OR OR AT PARTICULARLY
ASK QUESTIONS IF YOU WILL DIRECT
YOUR QUESTION TO ONE OF THE-
PALM FOR PLEASE SPECIFICALLY IF
YOU WANT ALL THREE. TO RESPOND
TO A QUESTION LET ME KNOW WHEN
AND WILL GO IN ORDER AND SENATOR
LAYERED LET ME IN FAIRNESS. YOU
WOULD LIKE TO START OF SUCH. AS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
IN. IT IS GREAT TO MEET CHIEF
PAIN IN- I'VE KNOWN SUPERVISOR
CHÁVEZ FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
IT'S GOOD TO SEE HER IN. A CHIEF
MILLS WAS THE POLICE CHIEF OF MY
HOMETOWN AND IT WAS A HUGE LOSS
WHEN HE- MOVED AT THE END OF
LAST YEAR. TO HIS NEW JOB AND
GLAD TO SEE HIM AGAIN- I AM
GOING TO ASK ONE OF THOSE
QUESTIONS THAT'S GOING TO GO TO
ALL THREE OKAY THEN I THINK IT'S
REALLY. IT'S THE GENERAL
CARESSED QUESTION THAT'S AT THE
HEART OF YOUR WORK AND YOU KNOW
ONE SPECIFIC SITUATION WE HAD
WITH REGARD TO CORRECTIONS WAS
WITH THE SAN DIEGO JAIL AND IT.
LED TO. TWO SUCH- OUR REACTION
THAT THERE WAS EVEN A STATE
AUDIT DONE OF SUPPORT WHAT WAS
SUPPORTED ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS
BY LEGISLATORS- FROM HERE AND MY
QUESTION IS IN YOUR ROLE AS A
BOARD MEMBER HOW DO YOU MAKE
SURE THAT YOU ARE ACTUALLY
FINDING OUT ABOUT ISSUES THAT
ARE GOING ON AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
AND BEING ABLE TO ADDRESS THEM
FROM YOUR A POSITION HOW DO YOU
JUST MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE STAYING ON TOP OF THESE.
THE SUPERVISOR CHÁVEZ LET ME ASK
YOU TO GO FIRST THEN WE'LL GO TO
CHIEF PAINS AND THEN TO CHIEF
MILLS. THANK YOU SENATOR LEARNED
SO MUCH FOR THE QUESTION AND
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN ALSO.
YOU KNOW I THINK- ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT THINGS THAT WE
CAN DO AS BOARD MEMBERS IS
REALLY WORK WITH THE VERY
TALENTED SMART STAFF WE HAVE AT
ESCC- I THINK THAT'S ONE THING I
THINK THE OTHER IS THAT WHEN WE
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES LOOK AT.
AUDITS NEWSPAPER ARTICLES OTHER
ISSUES THAT GET RAISED BY THE
PUBLIC IN THE COMMUNITY IT'S
REALLY TO LOOK FOR OPPORTUNITIES
TO INVESTIGATE THOSE AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE- I THINK THAT IN THE
IN THE INSTANCE THAT YOU REYES
WELL WHAT WAS MOST INTERESTING
TO ME IS THAT. THERE ARE LOTS OF
PEOPLE. AND SO USING AN AUDIT
TOOL OR OTHER KINDS OF COMMUNITY
TOOLS LIKE THAT ARE WE ON EARTH
CHALLENGES- AND THEN FRANKLY I
THINK THE OTHER THING WE SHOULD
BE THINKING ABOUT A ONE OF THE
TRENDS WE'RE SEEING ACROSS THE
STATE. BECAUSE THOSE TRENDS THAT
ALLOW US TO WORK WITH ALL OF
YOU. LOOK AT LEGISLATIVE
HEARINGS WHEN THEY'RE NECESSARY
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I CHIEF.
THANK YOU AGAIN. FOR THE
QUESTION WHY GREENWOOD STUFF
BUDGET DAMAGE HE'S NOT LISTENING
TO THE CONCERNS OF THE COMMUNITY
FOR THE ABILITY FOR THE YES YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO NUMBER ONE UP
TO BE ABLE TO ACT ON THOSE
CONCERNS I THINK THERE ARE
CRITICAL BUT THINK ONE THING
THAT WE WANT TO ALWAYS REMEMBER
THAT INDEFINITE BECAUSE HE IS-
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S AFFORDABLE
THE THING THAT WE CAN DO FOR.
THE SAUDIS THAT ENSURE THAT THE-
INCARCERATED PERSONS ARE SAFE
WHILE THEY ARE IN ANY OF OUR
GOAL ARE YOU WILL STILL BE CELL
NO I THINK- THERE HAVE TO BE
MECHANISM THANKS FOR ALLOW THE
PUBLIC IF THEY HAVE AT THE
MOVIES- QUARTERSTAFF NINE ONE
MAY HAVE INFORMATION FOR THEM TO
HAVE THE ABILITY AND. THE PLACE
. AND TO BE COMFORTABLE IN THE-
ABLE TO SHARE DATA FROM WITH
GET. ENOUGH FOR ME TO DRAW. THE
PUBLIC. WELCOME BACK IN PUT BACK
ON. FOR SO THAT- HE DIDN'T HAVE
- ROBUST ABOUT AN EXACT THE KIND
OF THE PEOPLE GOT IT. SAN DIEGO
ONE ONE BUT YEAH TO REMEMBER
MEETING WE WERE ABLE TO HAVE
SOME GOOD DESPITE ABOUT WHAT
WILL BE THE NEXT. ARE THE ORDER
TO- FRIDAY THANK MORE
INFORMATION. OUR VOTE THANK YOU
BY DEFAULT SO THAT THAT WOULD
GIVE PROVIDE. T. SAN DIEGO JEFF
. THEY YOU ARCHIE MILLS. WELL
SENATOR LAYERED THING YOU FOR
THE IN IT IS THE TO SEE YOU AS
WELL- I THE RATE WHAT WE NEED TO
DO AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
BEING A AWARE OF ALL THE ISSUE
THAT ARE TAKE PLACE AS A SEVERAL
FOR ONE WE NEED TO BE FULLY
IMMERSED. IN THE PER PERSON I
FULLY IMMERSED IN THE
INFORMATION THAT IS COMING TO US
FROM A VARIETY OF SOURCES.
PERSONAL CONTACTS ARE IMPORTANT.
IN A RELATIONSHIP TO BE ABLE TO
SPEAK DIRECTLY. WITH PEOPLE TO
FIND OUT WHAT'S GOING ON. IN
THESE LOCATIONS IS VITALLY
IMPORTANT NOT ONLY AT THE-
COUNTY JAIL LEVEL BUT ALSO IN
THE PROBATION DEPARTMENTS.
AROUND THE STATE THAT'S WHY IT'S
CRITICAL TO HAVE PEOPLE LIKE-
CHIEF AIDS. AIDS ON THE- BOARDS
WHERE HE CAN REACH OUT AND TALK
TO PEOPLE AND GET INFORMATION
FAIRLY QUICKLY. THE SECOND IS WE
HAVE TO TRUST OUR PROFESSIONAL
STAFF AT THE BSE SIX. THEY ARE
VERY BRIGHT CAPABLE THOUGHTFUL-
INTELLIGENT PEOPLE WHO I'VE GOT
TO HAVE A GREAT DEAL OF RESPECT
FOR. AND THEN LASTLY ARE TWO
MORE THINGS ONE IS WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT DATA.
STATEWIDE DATA TO FIND OUT- WHAT
EXACTLY IS GOING ON WHAT IS THAT
DATE I MEAN JUST OUTSIDE THE
STANDARD DEVIATION OF WHAT IS
TYPICAL FOR A- A FACILITY. I AM
LOOKING AT FOR INSTANCE PEOPLE
WHO CHOOSE. NOT TO REPORT OUT TO
CC. END UP PUTTING PRESSURE ON
THEM TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR-
COMING INTO COMPLIANCE. AND THEN
THE LAST THING IS I REALLY.
TRULY BELIEVE THAT SEEMS SO
IMPORTANT ON THE FOR THE BSE
SEAT OUT PEOPLE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE LIKE WE DO. ON THE
BOARD. BECAUSE THEY ARE ABLE TO
GIVE US SOME INSIGHT INFORMATION
THAT WE WOULD NOT. OTHERWISE
HALF AND SO I THINK THAT ALL
THOSE THINGS TOGETHER. WILL
ALLOW US TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
A VERY CUTE ACUTE AWARENESS OF
WHAT'S TAKING PLACE. IN THE
FACILITIES AROUND THE STATE. FOR
YOU AND I APPRECIATE THE ANSWER
OF ALL THREE OF YOU AND I KNOW
ALSO THAT. OUR SUPERVISOR CHAVEZ
SAID AT THE BEGINNING. THAT ARE
PART OF THIS IS A LEARNING
PROCESS WHERE YOU MIGHT REFLECT
US THINGS THAT. ARE NECESSARY OR
YOU'VE LEARNED OR WHAT THERE
MIGHT BE FURTHER ACTION AND I
WOULD INVITE ALL THREE OF YOU TO
DO THAT. I THINK THE LAST THING
I'D LIKE TO DO IS ASK A
QUESTION. A DIRECTLY OF
SUPERVISOR CHAVEZ AND THAT IS I
JUST KNOW- I THINK NOT EVEN FROM
TALKING TO YOU BUT FROM PRESS
ACCOUNTS AND WATCHING. THE TO
SANTA CLARA COUNTY JAIL HAS
BEEN- AND ISSUE AND I KNOW THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HAS TAKEN
AGGRESSIVE ACTION EVEN THOUGH
THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY IN
CHARGE OF THE JAIL. TO DEAL WITH
THIS WAS GOING TO ASK. BEFORE
YOU DESCRIBE THAT SITUATION AND
HOW IT IS IN FOUR THEM TO YOU
FOR SERVING IN THIS POSITION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER LAYERED
FOR THE QUESTION- YOU KNOW ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE
HAD HERE IS. A WELL WE'VE HAD A
NUMBER OF THEM BUT ONE REALLY
STARTED WHEN WE HAD OF A MURDER
IN OUR JAILS FIGHT TO. REXALL
OFFICERS. AND AND THIS HAPPENED
IN. TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. OR YEP
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND FROM
THAT POINT ON WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY FRANKLY WITH THE SHERIFF
AND ALL OF OUR PARTNERS TO DO
YOU. HAVE THE FBI AND OTHERS
COME IN AND INVESTIGATE TO
REALLY HELP US UNDERSTAND. WHAT
WASN'T WORKING IN OUR JAILS WHAT
DO WE NEED TO IMPROVE AND HOW WE
CAN IMPROVE IT. AND ONE OF THE
THINGS I WOULD SAY THAT I THINK
IT'S REALLY CRITICAL IS THAT.
THE EMPHASIS ON TRANSPARENCY THE
EMPHASIS ON ACCOUNTABILITY IS.
PARAMOUNT I THINK WHAT- WHAT I
WOULD SAY THAT THAT AS I THINK
ABOUT THE FUTURE I THINK ONE
THING THAT I'VE LEARNED IS THAT.
ALL THE INVESTIGATIONS AND ALL
THAT ALL THE CHANGES THAT WE
MAKE IN OUR INSTITUTIONS ARE
CRITICAL TRANSPARENCY IS
CRITICAL. BUT I WOULD SAY THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE STILL
WORKING ON IS HOW WE CHANGE THE
CULTURE. OF THESE INSTITUTIONS.
AND SOME OF THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT PHYSICAL DESIGN WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT LEADERSHIP WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT PURPOSE. WE ARE IN OUR
COUNTY ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
REBUILDING OUR JAIL AND ONE OF
THE CONCERT I HAVE ABOUT
REBUILDING IT IS THAT WE'RE-
BUILDING. A JAIL WHILE WE'RE IN
THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING THE
CULTURAL CHANGES WE MOST WANT TO
SEE OUR INSTITUTION. ON SO I
THINK THE WAY THAT'S PREPARED ME
AS BOTH UNDERSTAND THAT. EVEN
WITH ALL. THE BEST RULES IN
PLACE. YOU CAN STILL HAVE
MISTAKES AND WE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE AND- AN OBLIGATION TO BE
TRANSPARENT ABOUT IT. BECAUSE
MORE TRANSPARENT WE ARE THE MORE
WE HELP EACH OTHER ACROSS THE
STATE REALLY LEFT WHAT I THINK
ARE. PRETTY LOW STANDARDS IN
SOME INSTANCES. WE'RE. REALLY
TRYING TO- FRANKLY IF WE'RE-
RISK. ARE INSTITUTIONS HAVE TO
REFLECT THAT AND I THINK THAT'S
GIVEN ME I HAVE. A PERSPECTIVE
THAT'S BOTH ON THE GROUND BUT
RECOGNIZING THAT. THERE'S A LOT
OF CHANGE THAT COULD HAPPEN
STATEWIDE. THANK YOU I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT RESPONSE AND I
ALSO. RECOGNIZE THAT THAT JUST
HELPS BRING A LOT OF WITH YOU TO
THE BOARD- I APPRECIATE ALL
THREE OF YOU- RESPOND THANK YOU
VENTURE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MEADOW VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU
MADAM PROVED HIM AND THANK YOU
TO ALL OF YOU FOR STEPPING
FORWARD TO TAKE THIS VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ASSIGNMENT- I DO HAVE
A QUESTION FOR ALL THREE
REGARDING- RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN FLOATING AROUND GIVING
THE BOARD THE AUTHORITY TO
ENFORCE THIS REGULATIONS. SINCE
I THINK ONE OF THE TOP
PRIORITIES FOR YOUR BOARD IS
SETTING STANDARDS FOR INSPECTION
OF LOCAL DETENTION FACILITIES.
AND THE QUESTION IS WHAT ARE
YOUR THOUGHTS ON WHETHER YOU
SHOULD HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
ENFORCE REGULATIONS AND PERHAPS
THE CHALLENGES. ARM YOU KNOW THE
HIGH RISKS THAT SHARE OF SPACE
IN RUNNING LOCAL JAILS- THAT
NEED TO BE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION ARE IF THE BOARD
IS GRANTED THAT AUTHORITY AND
THAT KIND OF A COMPLICATED
QUESTION BUT I BELIEVE THE L. A.
O. WHEN I WAS LOOKING OUT TO.
THE ROLE AND THE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND THE
OUTCOMES THAT PERHAPS THE LACK
OF A CERTAIN TOOLS FOR
ENFORCEMENT MIGHT ENHANCE OUR
THE ABILITY OF YOUR OR BOARD TO
ACTUALLY DO THE JOB IN TERMS OF.
ENFORCEMENT OF THE- SETTING. SO
ADAM FOURTEEN MAYBE EACH ONE OF
THEM AND CERTAINLY FAR AND OUT
IF IT'S A UNCOMFORTABLE QUESTION
AND COULD SHE ON THE RECORD WAS
SOMETHING ARE YOU CAN BE BIG.
BUT I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
ONE FOR US TO UNDERSTAND WHEN
THAT COMES OUT OF IN. AN AUDIT
TO REVIEW BUYER L. A. OLD OUT
THERE MIGHT BE A TOOL IT'S
MISSING THAT WOULD HELP YOU MEET
ABOUT MOST IMPORTANT PRIORITY.
THANK YOU OUR CHIEF MILLS LET ME
ASK YOU TO START AND THEN WE'LL
GO TO A SUPERVISOR CHÁVEZ AND
THEN TO- CHIEF PAINS. SO WHAT
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION AND NOT IT REALLY GETS
TO THE HEART OF THE PURPOSE OF
THE B. S. YOU SEE AND WHAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE. IN THE FUTURE
AND OBVIOUSLY AS THE SENATE-
PRIORITIZE PRIVATE IT ROCKETED
TO. DETERMINE THE EXTENT TO
WHICH YOU WANT TO SEE
ENFORCEMENT CAPABILITY AT THE B.
S. C. CURRENTLY THERE REALLY IS
NONE. OTHER THAN TO CALL PEOPLE
TO- THE BSE AND HAVE THEM REPORT
OUT AS WE DID I JUST RECENTLY. I
THINK THIS YEAR MISPERCEPTION
ANI- WAS CALLED TO BE A CC TO
TESTIFIED TO EXPLAIN I HAD MET
ONE OF THE- CONDITIONS OF THE
REGULATIONS OF THE SEC. HE DID A
WONDERFUL PRESENTATION WAS ABLE
TO LEVERAGE THAT INTO OBTAINING
MORE STAFFING IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO ACTUALLY MEET. OTHER
CRITERIA YES YOU SEE HIMSELF OR
SO I THINK IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO CONTINUE TO
CALL PEOPLE FORWARD HAVE THEM
TESTIFY. I DO WANT TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT EACH OF US RECOGNIZES.
HOW DIFFICULT A JOB IT IS FOR
SHARE RUN A CUSTODY FACILITY NO
THAT IS NOT A SIMPLE TASK I WILL
FLY THE SHERIFF'S ALL OVER THE
STATE FOR THEIR ABILITY TO. RUN
AS BEST AS THEY CAN AND
PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATIONS GIVEN
LIMITATIONS THAT THEY HAVE OR
POLITICALLY AS WELL. AS REPORTS
WHY. I PUT IN THE SAME TIME WANT
TO MAKE SURE THE STANDARD ARE
CAP HIGH AND THAT MAY TWO. IN
MAY NEED TO TAKE. ENFORCEMENT
CAPABILITY. ARE REGULATED
REGULATORY CAPABILITY AT THE BSE
THE ONLY THING I WOULD SUGGEST
TO THE SENATE. IN THE
LEGISLATORS IS THAT IF YOU'RE
GOING TO DO THAT. THERE IT'S
VERY CLEAR WHERE THE RESOURCES
WILL COME FROM. AND SO THAT HOW
WE CAN SUPPORT THE STAFF TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT AND TO DO IT NAY
VERY THOUGHTFUL WAY- THIS NOT
HEAVY HANDED BUT AT THE SAME
TIME REALLY DOES EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO PROTECT THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE HOUSED. AT THE FACILITY
AT THE FACILITIES AS WELL AS-
THOSE WHO ARE WORKING AT THE
FACILITIES. THANK YOU FOR THAT
THAT QUESTION. THANK YOU SUPER
pAND THANK YOU SENATOR FOR THE
QUESTION. I WOULD JUST CAN KERR
WITH CHIEF MALES THAT- I THINK
HE'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT THE
RESPONSIBILITY THAT. IS BESTOWED
UPON THAT THE SEC IF THAT'S THE
WILL OF THAT. THE LEGISLATURE
I'M SHOULD BE YOU KNOW WHATEVER
RESPONSIBILITY SHOULD HAVE A
COMMENSURATE AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
SO FOR A COUPLE OF REASONS ONE
IS THAT. IF THERE ARE NEW-
RESPONSIBILITIES AND YOU WITH
THE WORDY GIVEN WE WOULD WANT
THE AUTHORITY TO BE MEANINGFUL.
AND NOT EVEN IF WE WOULD WANT
THE AUTHORITY AND WITH THE
COMMUNITIES EXPECTATIONS ARE TO
MATCH. UP BECAUSE I THINK ONE OF
THE CHALLENGES FOR THE SEC IS
THAT THEIR PEOPLE ENOUGH IN THE
COMMUNITY YOU THINK THAT IT HAS
A LOT MORE. POWER THAN IT THAN
IT CURRENTLY DOES TO BE ABLE TO
RESOLVE- SOME OF THESE ISSUES SO
THAT THAT- SOURCE AND THEN THE
COMMENSURATE INDICATIONS OF THAT
EVERYBODY REALLY UNDERSTANDS
WHAT THE CAPACITY OF THE SEC IS.
I THINK WOULD BE IDEAL. THE ONLY
OTHER THING I WOULD ADD IS THAT.
YOU KNOW THE UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE LEGISLATURE I
THINK YOU ALL HAVE BEEN VERY
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THE KINDS OF
REFORMS AND CHANGES THAT YOU
WANT TO SEE ON THE GROUND. I
THINK BEING ABLE TO RAISE SOME
OF THE MINIMUM STANDARDS
AGAINST. SOME MORE CONSISTENCY
ACROSS THE STATE- IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND I THINK IF THE
LEGISLATURE WORK TO- GIVE THE
SEC MORE. AUTHORITIES THEN I
THINK THE OTHER POINT THAT SHE
FELL ST I JUST WANNA RELAX THAT
RARITY ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT THAT.
THE WHERE YOU THINK THAT- WHAT
KIND OF A- TOOL WE WOULD HAVE
WOULD BE WITH YOU. OFF I THANK
YOU CHIEF. THANK YOU CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK- SAM I WAS TOLD THAT
MY IDEA WASN'T THAT GREAT WE CAN
HEAR YOU GREAT NOW IT WAS SO IT
THERE WERE MOMENTS WHERE IT WAS
A LITTLE MUFFLED BEFORE BUT WE
COULD STILL MAKE IT OUT BUT THIS
IS MUCH BETTER THANK YOU OKAY.
VERY GOOD OKAY- THANK YOU AGAIN
SENATOR FOR THE QUESTION IN
ITSELF YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S A
COMPLICATED ANSWER IN IN A WAY
BECAUSE HAVING GONE THROUGH YES
YOU SEE ADDICTS AT MY GLOBAL
FACILITY OFFICIALS THEREFORE FOR
THE ARTISTS NOT I THINK WHAT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE REGARDING THE
INSPECTIONS THAT YOU COME INTO
THE WORK ON BEHALF OF BSE C.
WHICH ARE. PROFESSIONAL FOLKS
WHO WORK FOR- JOB OF TAKING A
LOOK AT WHAT THE SITUATIONS ARE
BRINGING TO LIFE- CONCERNS
AROUND- WHAT REGULATIONS MAY-
BE- VIOLATION AT THAT TIME THE
NAME PROVIDING THE PROFESSIONAL
SUPPORT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
ISSUES ARE REALLY- I BELIEVE IF
THE YES YOU SEE IF GIVEN THAT
AUTHORITY OF INVESTIGATORY FORTY
IN ADDITION TO THE REGULATORY
FORTY IT JUST IT CHANGES THE
RELATIONSHIP. OF A BIT IN IN I
THINK IN A WAY THAT I THINK THE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT HAVE BEEN
BUILT OVER THE YEARS ON WHETHER
TO BE ADULT OR A JUVENILE
FACILITIES I THINK IT'S ONE
THAT'S BEEN. ON. PROFESSIONALISM
OF BOTH YOU KNOW- JAILS- STAFF
HERE IN OUR JUVENILE WHOLE. AS
WELL AND THEN BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE. THE TECHNICAL SUPPORT
YOUR FOR THEM TO RUN. ISSUES
THAT MAY HAPPY- I. GIVEN THERE
FORTY YES HAS NOW IN UNDERSTOOD
AND FROM. SHE WAS CORRECT IN WE
HAD. MERCED DECADE SHERIFF'S. IN
THE- THAT. THAT BECAUSE OF THE
WORK THAT GETS USED AT THE-
BECAUSE OF THE- RECOMMENDATIONS
CAME FROM THE PSEC THEY WERE
ABLE TO. THE TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
TO THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT TO
HAVE ADDITIONAL STAFF. WHICH IS
LEADING TO SOME. ABU THAT. SO
I'M THAT WOULD BE MY ONLY-
REGARD TO- ADDING THAT
ADDITIONAL BASKETS WORRYING
ASPECT OF THE WORK THAT THE SEC
WOULD BE DRAWING- IS THAT THERE
THERE COULD BE SOME KIND OF A
RELATIONSHIP CHANGE THAT AND- IS
THAT THE ANSWER TO THAT- SOME
OTHER ENTITY I'M NOT SURE. BUT-
I THINK THE REGULATORY AUTHORITY
THAT WE DO HAVE NOW WITH THE SEC
AND GIVEN THE SUPPORT THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE TO FACILITIES ONCE
LIKE THINGS ARE UNIFIED- I THINK
IT'S- IT'S BEEN. AFFECTED BUT OF
COURSE THERE ARE ALWAYS PLACES
WHERE WE CAN IMPROVE AND DO SOME
MORE. THANK YOU CHIEF WELL THANK
YOU ARE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR RESPONSES AS YOU MENTIONED-
SHE PAINS IT'S A VERY
COMPLICATED. ISSUE AND TO THAT
END BRINGING THE STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER TO REALLY TAKE A LONG
HARD LOOK AT WHAT MIGHT BE
NEEDED AND CERTAINLY THAT WOULD
BE SOMETHING THAT WOULD FIND
ITSELF INTO LEGISLATION I THINK
IS A VERY VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION TO HAVE GOING
FORWARD IS VERY DISTURBING TO US
CERTAINLY AND TO THE PUBLIC WHEN
THESE REPORTS COME OUT ABOUT
SOME OF THE DEFICIENCIES IN YOU
KNOW- FOR- AND SOME OF. THE
INCIDENCES TAKE PLACE IN OUR
JAILS I WAS A MEMBER OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND WE HAD A VERY
VERY SERIOUS IDEA THE JAILS ARE
AT THE HANDS OF SOME OF THE
CUSTODIAL MEMBERS SO- I'D LIKE
IT TO GO FORWARD- CERTAINLY ARE
RISES TO I NEED BUT CERTAINLY
ONE THAT HAS TO BE LOOKED AT
VERY CAREFULLY AND ENSURE THAT
WE DON'T HAVE CONFLICTS WE DON
IN SOMEHOW UNDERMINE. ARE YOU
MOST IMPORTANT ROLE OF SETTING
STANDARDS AND REGULATIONS SO
SOMETHING THAT I WILL CONTINUE
TO LOOK OUT AND- DO WISH ALL OF
YOU WELL I THINK A COMMENT FROM
OUR CHIEF HE MEANS I BELIEVE IT
WAS REGARD HAD DIFFICULTY IN OUR
JAILS IN THE NEW ROLE THAT OUR
SHARE OF SAN OUR LOCAL. LAW
ENFORCEMENT POLICE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH THESE DAYS WE HAVE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROBLEMS IT
ALMOST IT THREE ARE CENTER I
UNDERSTAND FOR THOSE WHO ARE
WIND UP THERE ARE ON TO KEEP
MANY OCCASIONS UNFORTUNATELY OF
LATE SO- YOU CERTAINLY HAVE MY
SUPPORT AND- WILL WORK ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE GOING
FORWARD THANKS FOR YOUR THOUGHTS
AND CERTAINLY CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR. POINT APPOINTMENT FOR.
THANK MADAM VICE- SENATOR TOM.
THANK YOU MADAM FOR THANK YOU-
TO EACH OF YOU ALL FOR YOUR WORK
IN THIS SPACE CHIEF MAILS YOU-
MENTIONED THAT YOU WANT TO
APPLAUD ALL OF- THE SHERIFF'S
AND WHO ARE DOING. VERY HARD
WORK MANAGING EACH OF THE JAILS
ARE COUNTIES- BUT I
UNFORTUNATELY AM NOT GOING TO
APPLAUD- ONE AND I COME FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND I HAVE TO SAY
WE HAVE A HUGE CHALLENGE WITH
OUR- JAILS AND WITH OUR
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT THERE I DO
AGREE THAT IT IS NOT EASY WORK-
BUT I DO THINK THE WORK NEEDS TO
BE HUMANE- I ONLYHAVE TWO
QUESTIONS I DO WANT TO SAY- LAST
YEAR WHEN I WAS. WORKING TWO OR
TWO YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS WORKING
ON THE CRISIS ACT ONE OF IT'S A
GRANT ADMINISTERED PROGRAM
DEALING WITH COMMUNITY RESPONSES
TO NINE ONE ONE. AND THERE WAS A
DESIRE TO HAVE THE PROGRAM
HOUSED IN B. SEC. AND THERE WAS
HUGE PUSH BACK. FROM THE
ADVOCATES ON WHO REALLY DID NOT
FEEL THAT- OUR FORMATIVE PROGRAM
LIKE THAT SHOULD BE HOUSED IN
THE SEC THEY DIDN'T THINK IT WAS
APPROPRIATE. AND THEY DIDN'T
THINK THAT- THE BOARD HAD THE
ABILITY THE COMPETENCY TO REALLY
ADMINISTER IT I'M GIVEN WHAT
IT'S TRYING TO ACHIEVE. AND I
THINK ABOUT SOME OF THAT
RELUCTANCE AND HESITANCY IS
BECAUSE OF THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
COME UP IN. AUDITS AND ARTICLES
I'M OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
ABOUT WHAT. IS GOING ON AND THE
FACT THERE THERE DOESN'T SEEM TO
BE ANY CONSEQUENCES. FOR-
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE NOT IN
COMPLIANCE. SO YOU KNOW WHEN I
THE AUDITED. THREE JAIL SYSTEMS
THREE DEPARTMENTS THREE
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT THE ALAMEDA
FRESNO AND LOS ANGELES BECAUSE
OF SO MANY REPORTS THAT WERE
COMING OUT FROM EACH OF THOSE
COUNTIES ABOUT THINGS THAT WERE
HAPPENING AND YOU KNOW THE AUDIT
WAS NOT GREAT- IT WAS NOT GREAT
SO MY FIRST QUESTION HAS TO DO
WITH DATA BECAUSE- YOU ALL
MENTIONED THAT. AND IT DOES SEEM
THAT. HI THERE THE PROVIDE THE
PROFILE SURVEYS OUR VOLUNTARY
FOLKS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO SUBMIT
INFORMATION- BECAUSE IT'S
VOLUNTARY WHAT'S COLLECTED IS
VERY LIMITED- AND THERE ISN'T A
LOT OF INFORMATION I THINK THAT
PROBABLY IS GLEANED FROM THE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE ASKED-
REGARDLESS OF HOW PEOPLE RESPOND
TO THEM SO I JUST LIKE TO KNOW
FROM EACH OF YOU. ARM DO YOU
THINK YOU YOU SAID WE NEED MORE
DATA AND MORE DATA IS IMPORTANT
WHAT KIND OF DATA WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO YOU THAT IS NOT BEING
COLLECTED NOW THAT YOU COULD USE
TO HELP BETTER INFORM DECISIONS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS AND
STANDARDS. THAT COME FROM THE
BOARD. THANK YOU AND YOU WANT
THAT OF ALL THREE YES THANK YOU-
CHIEF PAINS LET ME ALLOW YOU TO
GO FIRST- THIS TIME AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO CHIEF MILLS AND
THEN- SUPERVISOR TRAVIS. THANK
YOU- CENTER KAMLAGER FOR.
WESTERN IRAQ. WERE WE WERE I
MEAN FOR AS WELL. YEAH YEAH-
ASSEMBLY WITH IN THAT WE ARE A
LOT OF WAS WATCHING SOME CHIEF
WE ARE WE ARE NOW HAVING A
LITTLE BIT OF TROUBLE HEARING
YOU AGAIN SO LET'S SAW. I SEE IF
WE CAN OMEHOW MAKE THAT BETTER
YOU ARE DOING GREAT- HELLO. KEEP
TALKING CHIEF WILL WILL ASSESS
THAT SITUATION WILL DO AN
INSPECTION AND DETERMINE. RIGHT
BUT AGAIN THANK YOU US
UNDERGROUND WATER. WE ARE WE'RE
HOPEFUL THAT YOU KNOW IT AS WHAT
HAS HAPPENED SINCE THE AUDIT
THAT ON THE FRESNO. SHARES THE
PARTY DID HAVE IS YOUR TAKING A
LOOK AT- SOMEBODY THERE ARE NOT
SOME VEHICLES YOU THAT'S WHERE
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT THE
AUDIT- TOOK A LOOK AT I'M TAKING
A LOOK AT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT THE- COMMITTEE CORRECTIONS
PARTNERSHIP- AND HOW. WE COULD
SUPPORT- MORE PROGRAMMING IN THE
THINGS THAT COULD BE HAPPENING
THERE YOU KNOW WHEN I THINK
ABOUT WHAT KIND OF DATA COULD
HELP TO HELP TO DETERMINE WHAT
KINDS OF THINGS CAN IN JAILS
BENEFIT FROM. OUR SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE BASS- RECENTLY
WITH THE SAN DIEGO SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IS TO FIND OUT MORE
ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND HEALTH. ASSESSMENTS ARE
BEING ADMINISTERED- HELP GET AN
IDEA GETTING AN IDEA OF A
BASELINE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
JAIL TODAY SO THAT YOU CAN LOOK
AT AND SEE ARE THEIR BEST
PRACTICES THAT ARE HAPPENING
ACROSS THE STATE. ESPECIALLY
AMOUNTS ARE OUR BIGGER FACILITY
RIGHT SO I THINK LOOKING AT BACK
HUNDRED DOWN. TO DETERMINE WHAT
KINDS OF THINGS R. THE JAILS
WILL BE BEFORE WE DON'T SEE
THOSE KINDS OF ISSUES HAPPEN
ESPECIALLY IN OUR LARGER
FACILITIES WHAT WHAT ARE THEY
GOING RIGHT WHAT ARE THEY DOING
THAT OTHER FACILITIES WILL NOT
BE DOING. BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT'S THE ROLE OF YES. IS TAKE
A LOOK. AT THE STATE WIDE. OF
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING. IN ALL. HE THIS
UPSIDE LOWER- AMONGST THE- AND
SO. I THINK THE BSE'S CARE- YEAH
THE SERVER DATA OF THE FROM.
WHICH CAN ALLOW FOR. IT LOCATION
IDEAS ENTERED IN EVIDENCE
RECEIVING ALCOHOL- TO BE ABLE
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT ARE THE GOOD
I WHAT OF THINGS HAPPENING THOSE
. AROUND THE HEALTH BROWN'S.
INTEGRATION BACK FAMILIAR- L.
PROGRAM THAT'S BEING OFFERED. TO
OUR TO OUR FOLKS BETTER CUSTODY.
WHAT KIND OF. THINGS CAN-
REQUIRED. THE JAILS PROVIDE SO
THAT WE CAN TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE
THINGS THAT ARE WORKING. TO THE
BEST OF THEIR ABILITY AND THEN
WITH THAT INFORMATION THE SEC
WHICH I BELIEVE- DOES HAVE THE
ABILITY. TO BE ABLE TO
ADMINISTER ARE. YOU KNOW
BRINGING ABOUT THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEM TO
IMPROVE THROUGH- BROWN
OPPORTUNITIES- OR OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO SEE SOME BETTER. THANK YOU. I
CAN DO THAT BETTER THAT WAS GOOD
THAT WAS GOOD I BELIEVE
EVERYBODY WAS ABLE TO HEAR THAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH- SUPERVISOR
SERVICE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT QUESTION IT'S AN IMPORTANT
ONE US SENATOR AND- AND LET ME
JUST GIVE A COUPLE OF. BROAD
OBSERVATIONS ABOUT THE KIND OF
INFORMATION I THINK THAT WOULD
BE HELPFUL FOR US TO UNDERSTAND
AGAIN LOOKING BOTH AT PARTICULAR
FACILITIES BUT ALSO STATEWIDE.
ONE IS THAT RIGHT NOW- AS YOU
ALL KNOW. THE PEOPLE WHO COME
INTO CUSTODY FOR THE MOST PART
ARE RELATIVELY UNHEALTHY- FROM A
POPULATION PERSPECTIVE. AND
KNOWING WHAT SOMEONE'S HEALTH IS
WHEN THEY ENTER- AND WHETHER OR
NOT THEIR HEALTH IS. WHAT KINDS
OF SERVICES THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACCESS. IS REALLY CRITICAL SO
FOR EXAMPLE. WHAT ARE THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THEY GET MENTAL
HEALTH SCREENINGS HOW MANY OF
THEM END UP WITH THE DIAGNOSIS
HOW MANY OF THEM ARE GETTING
MEDICATION. YOU KNOW I THAT THAT
ALL OF THAT INFORMATION WILL
HELP US UNDERSTAND BOTH THE
POPULATIONS THAT ARE COMING IN.
HOW BETTER TO STRUCTURE THAT
THE- EM MEDICAL SERVICES THAT
ARE NOW. AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
SERVICES ARE IN A WAY THAT
REALLY DO GIVE PEOPLE THE BEST
OPPORTUNITY FOR AGAIN NOT TO
RECEIVE A- AN EXAMPLE OF THAT
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES I'VE SEEN
EVEN LOCALLY IS THAT- THERE ARE
SO MANY CONCERNS ABOUT HALF
FIVE. BUT NOT EVERYBODY IS IN
THE JAIL HAS ACCESS TO THE TO
THE INFORMATION THAT COULD HELP
THEM ACTUALLY SUPPORT PEOPLE. ON
THEIR WAY OUT AND SO THOSE ARE
THE KINDS OF ISSUES THAT IF WE
IF WE WERE ABLE TO GATHER DATA
BOTH SPECIFIC INSTITUTE. WHAT
THE TAKE A LOOK AT IT AND THEN
BETTER UNDERSTAND. HOW TO
UTILIZE THAT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE LOWERING RECIDIVISM AS AN
EXAMPLE- ANOTHER EXAMPLE THAT I
THOUGHT THE L. A- REACHED OUT
THAT. THEN I THOUGHT WAS
INTERESTING WAS REPORTING ON
DEATHS IN A MORE ROBUST WAY. I
THINK REPORTING TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OR SOMEWHERE THAT REALLY
DOES MAKE. THAT ADD SUNSHINE TO
THAT. IS REALLY IMPORTANT- AND
PART OF THE REASON FOR THAT I
THINK IS THAT IF EVERYBODY HAS
TO. HAVE REPORTS THAT ARE
CONSISTENT AND CLEAR. AND
OPPORTUNITY TO THE LOOKOUT WHAT
ARE THE CHANGES THAT NEED TO BE
MADE IN EACH FACILITY. AND THEN
IN AGGREGATE WHAT ARE THE
CHANGES THAT WE NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT. ON THAT WILL
IMPROVE THE- SAFETY AND WELL
BEING OF THOSE ARC STUDIO CARE
AND AGAIN. YEAH WELL THE MEASURE
THE INPUTS WE HAVE WHAT THE
RECIDIVIST. I'M OUT. THANK YOU
OUR CHIEF MILLS. THANK YOU AT
THE CENTER CALM WATER FOR THE
FOR THE QUESTION AND I. IN MY
SENSE WE NEED A DATE AT TWO
LEVELS ONE IS AT THE MACRO LEVEL
WHAT'S HAPPENING STATEWIDE WHERE
THE TRENDS. ARE THERE ARE
CONSISTENT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IN HOUSE THAT IMPACT THE LOCAL
FACILITY AND THEN AT THE MICRO
LEVEL. WE ALSO NEED. BETTER DATA
IN TERMS OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
INSIDE FACILITIES THERE'S- A
SERIES OF USES OF FORCE IS FOR
INSTANCE ON. INMATES WIRELESS
TAKING PLACE AND WHAT IS THAT
DATA LOOK LIKE ARE WE EVEN
CAPTURING THE RIGHT DATA AND UP
MY I'M SUSPICIOUS THAT WERE
PROBABLY NOT. I CAPTURE THE
RIGHT DATA. SO I SEE THE DATA
NEED TO COME OUT AT TWO
DIFFERENT LEVELS. FOR INSTANCE I
WAS MENTIONED BY CHIEF HAYNES-
THE- BY THE JAILS THE LOCAL
JAILS HAVE BECOME THE LARGEST
MENTAL HEALTH FACILITY IN THE
STATE. IN TRYING TO RUN A
FACILITY WHERE THAT IS PRESENT
AND ALONG WITH THE ENORMOUS
ADDICTION PROBLEMS. THAT IS
WHERE WE NEED THE INFORMATION TO
BE ABLE TO DETERMINE THE BEST
WAY TO RUN THESE FACILITIES SO
THAT WHEN WE PROMULGATE A
REGULATION THAT ALLOWS US TO. BE
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT HOW WE'RE DOING
AT. AND THEN THE LAST PART OF
THAT IS THE INFORMATION THAT IS
NEEDED- IS WHAT WHAT COUNTIES
ARE BEING THOUGHTFUL ABOUT HOW
THEY REPORT OUT FOR INSTANCE
DURING COVERED THEIR WORDS THERE
WERE DEPARTMENTS JUST CHOSE NOT
TO GIVE THE INFORMATION AND THAT
CANNOT E ACCEPTABLE AND NOT IN
A STATE BUT- BSE IS POWERLESS TO
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT OTHER THAN
TO NOTATE IT. AND ALLOW THE
DECISION MAKERS WHICH ARE THE
PEOPLE ON THE COUNTIES PEOPLE
LIKE TO THE SHERIFF'S I DO HAVE
THAT INFORMATION IF THEY CHOOSE
TO SEEK IT OUT I SAID THEY CAN
MAKE A DETERMINATION ON WHAT
pKIND OF LEADERS. DO THEY WANT
PLACE. THANK YOU FOR THAT I
THINK. I AGREE THERE SHOULD BE
ARM. MUCH MORE TEETH THAT YOU
ALL HAVE I MEAN I YOU KNOW. YOU
CAN HAVE STANDARDS- BUT YOU ALSO
HAVE TO HAVE CONSEQUENCES IF
THINGS AREN'T BEING FOLLOWED-
AND SO I AGREED THAT WE SHOULD
BE LOOKING AT GIVING THE BOARD
GREATER AUTHORITY- A END. I
THINK SOME CONCERN IS. WOULD
THIS GIVEN THE MAKEUP OF THE
BOARD IS THIS A BOARD THAT CAN
LEVY- YOU KNOW ENFORCEMENT THE
AND CONSEQUENTIAL DECISIONS- TO
COLLEAGUES YOU KNOW THE FOLKS
KIND OF FROM THE SAME STRIPES
AND SO THAT'S GOING TO HAVE TO
BE HOPEFULLY IS THAT THE-
HOPEFULLY YOU ALL ARE HAVING OR
WILLING TO ENGAGE IN DISCUSSIONS
AROUND THAT. BECAUSE WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT CULTURE CHANGE YOU
KNOW THAT'S ALSO A PART OF IT.
YOU KNOW MY SECOND QUESTION
REALLY STEMS FROM THAT AND IT'S
SPECIFIC TO LOS ANGELES COUNTY-
I THINK- A SUPERVISOR CHÁVEZ
MENTIONED THAT YOU GET
INFORMATION OBVIOUSLY FROM DOING
LOTS OF READING AND THERE ARE
TONS OF NEWSPAPER ARTICLES THAT
HAVE COME OUT ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN OUR L. A. COUNTY
JAILS. I HAVE ONE HERE THAT WAS
DONE MAYBE JUST A WEEK OR SO AGO
THAT. TALKS ABOUT YOU KNOW
HUMILIATING STRIP SEARCHES AND
PUNCHING INCARCERATED PEOPLE IN
THE HEAD AND HAVING FOLKS WALK
AROUND. YOU KNOW WITHOUT.
UNDERWEAR OR SHOES YOU KNOW-
STILL USING THE RAP DEVICE-
WHICH IT IS THIS IS A CONTINUING
PRACTICE SHOULD CANNOT BE
JUSTIFIED- AND SO. IF FOLKS ARE
NOT I MEAN SO WHAT IS GOING ON
IT'S REALLY THE QUESTION WHAT IS
GOING ON AND WHAT WHAT CAN WE DO
BECAUSE IT IS EVIDENCE THAT
WHILE ARM. SHARESARE PART OF A
LOCAL SYSTEM IN THE JAIL AS PART
OF A LOCAL SYSTEM AND YOU HAVE A
LOCAL BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IT
ALSO SEEMS LIKE SOME OF THESE
ENTITIES NEED SOME HELP FROM THE
STATE. AND SO. I MEAN WHAT ARE
YOUR THOUGHTS. DO YOU ARE LET'S
PICK A PERSON I. LET LET YOU
KNOW I IT'S SO HARD WE HAVE A
COURT REPORTER WHO TRANSIT IN
NAMES AND SO LET ME DO LET ME
JUST STEP RIGHT IN AND-
SUPERVISOR CHÁVEZ IT ANYTHING
YOU WANT TO SAY IN RESPONSE TO
THIS AND THEN I'LL O TO CHIEF
MILLS AND THEN- CHIEF PAINS.
YES- YOU KNOW I. AS CENTER COME
UNDER I THINK THAT THE FIRST
QUESTION YOU ASKED ABOUT WHETHER
OR NOT WE CAN HOLD EACH OTHER
ACCOUNTABLE. IS A FAIR QUESTION
LIKE AND I AND I WILL SAY I'VE
I'VE- BEEN ON THE BOARD. FOR A
VERY SHORT TIME MY OBSERVATION
IS THAT BOTH MYSELF AND MY
COLLEAGUES TO DO THAT. I THINK
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT-
WHEN YOU DECIDE YOU WANT TO BE
OUT OF WORK LIKE THIS THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT ONE OF THE
IMPLICATIONS OF IT IS THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO BE- YOU. YOU YOU
ARE GETTING IN THERE BECAUSE YOU
THINK THINGS CAN BE BETTER. AND
YOU YOU'RE GOING TO BE HEARD ON
THAT AND YOU YOU WANT TO BE
HEARD ON THAT SO THAT THAT'S ONE
THING I WOULD JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
ABOUT MY COLLEAGUES AND I THINK.
THE OTHER IS THAT THE IMPORTANCE
OF HAVING THE TWO FOLKS ON THE
BOARD THAT HAVE LIVED EXPERIENCE
IS REALLY CRITICAL. TO SHEDDING
LIGHT AND REALLY REINFORCING
WHAT NEEDS TO CHANGE. I DO WANT
TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THE
LIMITATIONS OF THE SEC'S.
AUTHORITY AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
DISCUSSING- OF YOU KNOW. BACK
AND FORTH I. YOU KNOW AS TO
WHAT'S HAPPENING SPECIFICALLY IN
LOS ANGELES THANK YOU KNOW MY
INFORMATION IS REALLY MORE FROM-
FROM READING AND I WILL JUST
MAKE ONE OBSERVATION. THAT THE
PRODUCTS ARE PATIENT AND IT'S
OBVIOUS THAT THEIR- THEIR
SUFFERING AND THAT THEY'RE IN
TROUBLE AND THAT IN I DON'T I
DON'T MEAN. WITH ANYBODY I MEAN
THAT THERE'S TROUBLE OUT THERE.
I THINK WHAT THAT MEANS IS
ABSOLUTELY THAT THERE'S A WALL
BOTH FOR. THE FCC TO WAIT AGAIN.
AND FOR THE STATE TO LOOK AT
WHETHER OR NOT THE KEY WORDS
THAT COME OUT OF THE- THE
INVEST. ONE IT SHOULD BE LIKE
JUST IT AND I'LL JUST GIVE AN
EXAMPLE OF WHERE THEY ARE THAT
MAY BE AN OPPORTUNITY AND MAYBE.
OR NOT. SO WHEN I LOOKED AT THE-
ELLIE OCI EVALUATE. SORRY AUDIT
OF. GO ONE OF THE THINGS I WAS
STRUCK BY WAS I THOUGHT OH THIS
IS A GREAT RECOMMENDATION ON.
HOW WE REPORT GAS. PUTTING THAT
IN THE HANDS OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR MAKING THAT PUBLIC.
I LOOKED AT THE MEDICAL
RECOMMENDATIONS AND THE QUESTION
I HAD WAS. WHAT WOULD MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS SAY ABOUT THIS
COMPONENT OF IT. AND SO I'M NOT
SURE WHICH OF THOSE PIECES NEEDS
TO BE EMBEDDED IN LEGISLATION
BECAUSE YOU'D ALWAYS FIND. OUT
THE- BEST PRACTICES. EIGHT AND
SO. I SAY THAT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT AS WE'RE LOOKING AT THESE
CASES THAT WE NEED TO DIVE IN AS
DEEP AS WE- CAN. SO THAT THE
SOLUTIONS. THAT WE SEE. CAN BE
PROPERLY DETERMINED WHAT SHOULD
BE LEGISLATIVE. WHAT SHOULD BE A
DIFFERENT KIND. OF PRACTICE I
DON'T KNOW ALL OF THE TOOLS THAT
I WOULD ONE. I WANT TO GET MORE
THOUGHT TO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE- SORRY CHIEF MILLS. YES
THANK YOU- I THINK WE'RE ALL
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CONDITIONS AND THE L. A. COUNTY
SYSTEM BOTH AT THE I'D AT THE
JAIL LEVELS WELLS THAT YOU'VE IN
ALL LEVELS ARE THESE ARE-
SUBSTANTIAL ISSUES I KNOW IT'S
BEEN A GREAT DEAL OF EFFORT AND
I HAVE I MY TENURE ON THE BSE
WHICH HAS NOT BEEN THAT LONG IT
JUST FEW YEARS. THIS IS BEEN THE
STRONGEST YES THIS YEAR HAS BEEN
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO HOLD A
SYSTEM ACCOUNTABLE I THINK THAT
THERE IS A LACK OF AUTHORITY TO
ACTUALLY DO SOME OF THOSE THINGS
HOWEVER- BECAUSE THIS IS A
DEMOCRACY IN AND THE- SHERIFF
WAS ELECTED I THINK THAT THERE
IS SOME- RIGHT THAT GOES WITH
THAT. HOWEVER WHEN YOU'RE SEEING
SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS THAT IS WHEN
THE STATE SHOULD STEP IN. THAT
IS WHEN THE STATE SHOULD- HOLD
PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE NOT WHATEVER
FORMAT THAT LOOKS LIKE I AM NOT
SURE- BUT I THAT COULD BE GIVEN
TO THE BSE AS LONG AS THE-
ABILITY TO DO IT. IS ALL THAT
GOES ALONG WITH THAT. THE LAST
THING I THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MENTION IS. PEOPLE
CONFUSE THE COUNTY JAIL SYSTEM.
WITH THE CAPACITY IN THE ABILITY
OF THE STATE PRISON SYSTEM. I
WE'VE MADE A CONSCIOUS DECISION
IN THE STATE TO BE
INSTITUTIONALIZED PRESENCE I
THINK THAT'S INAPPROPRIATE- MMHM
PROCEDURE AND AN ID IDEOLOGY
HOWEVER THE EXECUTION OF IT IS
VERY IMPORTANT ADD TO
INCARCERATE PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE
IN A IN A STATE PENAL
INSTITUTION FOR YOU KNOW FOR
YEARS KEEPING AMANDA AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL HAS REALLY MADE A
VERY COMPLEX AND MORE COMPLEX
THAN IT NEEDS TO BE SO THAT IS
PART OF THE SOLUTION THAT WE
NEED TO CONSIDER. AND TO THINK
THROUGH AS WE DO THAT- BECAUSE
IT IS OVERWHELMING I THINK FOR
MAYBE THE LOCAL INSTITUTIONS-
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO ACTUALLY A SMALL
CYMBALS PROBLEMS. THANK YOU
CHIEF CHIEF HAYNES. THANK YOU.
WEST NO MORE ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENING YOU SHOULD BE WE WILL
ARE NOT HEARING YOU AGAIN I'M SO
SORRY- BUT WE WANT TO HEAR YOU.
YEAH YOU'RE- YEAH CAN YOU HEAR
ME. FAMOUS LAST WORDS I YOU'RE
ON MUTE AND CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW
. THAT'S GOOD GO AHEAD MARZULLO
THE- I APPRECIATE CHIEF MILLS WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE L. A.
COUNTY SYSTEM AS A WHOLE BECAUSE
OF COURT THAT I MADE OUR LAST
YES YOU SEE IT. IS THAT. YOU
KNOW THE THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN LOS ALAMOS LOS
ANGELES BOTH MEN IN THE ADULT
SYSTEM AND IN THE IN OUR DOUBLE
FAULT IS THAT IT'S ON EXCEPT-
THERE IS NO REASON WHY SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT YOU TALK ABOUT
SYNERGY CAPITAL. THE STAFF IN
THERE ARE WAYS FOR- DEPARTMENTS
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE A LOOK AT-
HOW USE THE FORCE ARE HAPPENING
WITHIN THEIR FACILITIES. THERE
ARE- SAFETY PROTOCOLS- PROTOCOLS
FOR USE THE FORCE THERE IS A
SINGLE. USE OF FORCE THAT SHOULD
BE. THAT SHOULD BE HAPPENING IT
DOESN'T OPEN STEPS OUTSIDE OF
WHAT THE- WITH A FIFTY SAID.
THERE HAS TO BE A MEANS FOR-
STAFF TO BE ABLE TO BRING THAT
UP IT HAS TO BE A NEED FOR-
GARCIA PERSONS TO BE ABLE TO
BRING. THOSE KINDS OF- CONCERNS
TO THE TO THE- TO THE ATTENTION
OF STAFF INTO. THE
ADMINISTRATIVE. THAT'S THERE
THAT'S WE DO IN OUR TO FACILITY
THAT'S WHAT HAPPEN- IN LOS. IT'S
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S A- I CAN
UNDERSTAND THE STATE THE
WASHINGTON REALLY- PROVIDES
ASSISTANCE AND SUPPORT AND- EVEN
SOME MANDATE TO WHAT NEEDS TO BE
HAPPENING IN IN LOS ANGELES. I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
I'VE SAID IS THAT LOS ANGELES
REALLY NEEDS TO. YOUR GRACE THIS
THEMSELF- TAKING A LOOK AT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN L. A. COUNTY
THE COMMUNITY REALLY DOES NEED
TO GET A ONE PAGE RELIEF TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT IS THE BEST
REMEDY FOR WHAT YOU WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE ADULT SYSTEM
WHAT'S HAPPENING AND DIVORCES.
AND SOME KIND OF INVESTMENT IN
WHAT THE FACILITIES REQUIRED
WHAT KIND OF INVESTMENT YOU MAKE
IN THEIR FORTIES FOR TRAINING-
FOR- THE ABILITY. FOR I CAN TO
MAKE SURE THAT. ADDITIONAL
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE. IN LOS
WHERE. YOU IN ADULTS YOUR- TO-
BE ABLE TO MAKE- COMPLAINTS IN
OUR FAMILY MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO
BRING THOSE THINGS FORTY FOR
THEM TO BE ACTED UPON. IT MAY
MEAN I'M SOME KIND OF OBVIOUS
ADVERTISEMENT THAT HELPS TO DO
THOSE KINDS OF FORMS AND IN THAT
COUNTY. THERE NEEDS TO BE THAT
KIND OF THE SYSTEM THAT'S SET
UP- SO THAT THOSE THINGS CAN
HAPPEN BECAUSE SHE FEELS IS
RIGHT. THINK ABOUT WHAT'S
HAPPENED SINCE ONE NINE. IT SOME
FACILITIES. OR JUST BILL. TO FOR
YEARS AT A TIME- AND SO IT'S
GOING TO TAKE SOME COMMITMENT
FROM THE STATE I THINK TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO
LOCAL SO THAT WE CAN BUILD
QUALITY FACILITY. THAT MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR FACILITIES AT THE
SAME TIME BSE'S NEED TO BE ABLE
TO FIGHT FOR THE RIGHTS OF
CONSTRUCTION STRUCTURAL FAULTS
YOU. THE PROGRAM. IN ORDER TO-
TO. AT LEAST TAKE A LOOK AT
WHAT'S HAPPENING THE KIND OF
THINGS THAT YOU TALK ABOUT SORT
OF THE RATHER MEETING THIS
MORNING WILL YOUR WORK DONE FOR
THE MURDER OF POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION WE'LL TALK ABOUT THE
HOMELESS SITUATION AND IT'S- A
HUGE PROBLEM HERE IN FRESNO
COUNTY IN I CAN. SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING SOME OF OUR JAIL
SYSTEM IT'S MORE IT'S MORE THAN
JUST ONE ANSWER TO THIS QUESTION
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
TAKE A LOOK AT IN A
COMPREHENSIVEWAY VOTE BY
SYSTEMS WORKING OUT OF HIS MOUTH
THIS IS MORE THAN A FOR THE LAKE
COUNTY PROBATION OR DALY. BOB L.
A. COUNTY TO ADDRESS BECAUSE I
KNOW SHE ENOUGH IS ARE YOU ALL
OF THESE ARTISTS IN ORDER TO
MOVE ALL OF MY FOR NASA JUST CAL
BOTH THOSE ARE PEOPLE MAKING CO
. FOLKS WHO BEEN ON ARTS TO
BEFORE. THEY NEED TO BE ALL OF
TABLE ON THE SAME PAGE FIGURE
OUT WHAT THE SOLUTION. THANK YOU
THAT SHE PAINS I YOU KNOW I- I
AGREE WITH YOU THAT L. A. DOES
NEED TO WORK IT OUT AND GET IT
TOGETHER. THE OTHER PART OF THAT
IS THAT LA IS YOU KNOW. IN MY
OPINION. THE SHERIFF AND THE
DEPARTMENT IS A WEAK LINK IN A
STATE CHANGE- AND THAT IN THAT
MEANS THAT EVERYONE IS
CONNECTED. AND YOU KNOW I ALSO
SEE L. A. AS A CLARION CALL
BECAUSE THE LONGER IT TAKES TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES. THAT ARE
GOING ON IN LATE AND SOME OTHER
COUNTY QUITE FRANKLY YOU KNOW
THE MORE PUNITIVE LEGISLATION
WILL BECOME AND THE LESS
RELEVANT SOME BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS WILL BE SEEN. AND SO
I'M JUST CHARGING THAT EVERYONE
CONTINUE TO ROLL UP THEIR
SLEEVES AND TALK ABOUT
COLLECTIVELY WHAT WE CAN DO TO
IMPROVE THE SITUATION. IN OUR
COUNTIES AS IT RELATES TO OUR
ADULT IN OUR JUVENILE
FACILITIES- I ALSO WANT TO GO
BACK TO THE FACT THAT YES I AM-
ALSO RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING THE PUBLIC MEMBER- AND
THE COMMUNITY PROVIDER- BUT
THAT'S STILL JUST. A LOT OF
THIRTEEN AND THE MAJORITY OF THE
FOLKS THAT ARE ON THE BOARD HAVE
SOME- HISTORY WITH- YOU KNOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT- OR CORRECTIONS. AND
SO THAT STILL CAN SKEW
PERSPECTIVES AND DISCUSSIONS AND
MAYBE EVEN POSSIBLY DECISIONS AT
THE END OF THE DAY YOU KNOW AND
MAYBE THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO
THINK ABOUT HOW TO. MORE
DIVERSITY GUARDS TO YOU KNOW
BACKGROUNDS AND- BUT THAT'S NOT
ABOUT THIS SO I MIGHT GET OFF
THAT WILL SOAPBOX. AND I WANT TO
SAY- THANK YOU FOR ANSWERING MY
QUESTIONS- AND- FOR ACTUALLY
ANSWERING MY COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS AS WELL. THANK YOU
SENATOR COME LONGER- SENATOR
GROWTH. THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM
I APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WITH
ME AS I BOUNCE BACK AND FORTH-
ED I KNOW I MISSED SOME OF THE
COMMENTS BUT I DID CATCH THE
COMMENTS ABOUT- APPLAUDING OR
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT I THINK YOU
FOR THAT BECAUSE I THINK WITH AB
ONE OH NINE. OF COVIDIEN NOT
HAVING PRISONER TRANSFER BETWEEN
FACILITIES TO. OF OTHER STATE
RUN FACILITIES I THINK THAT OUR
SHARES HAVE DONE AN OUTSTANDING
JOB. OF MAKING SURE THAT- THE
PEOPLE ARE SAFE AT. THE END
THINGS ARE TAKEN CARE OF. I
THINK THAT OUR LOCAL SHERIFF'S
OFFICES ARE LOCAL JAILS HAVE
BECOME. A BECAUSE OF THE
SITUATIONS WITH ONE OH NINE AND
CO THAT THEY HAVE BECOME A MORE
AT THE PENITENTIARY OUR PRISON
SYSTEM VERSUS A- BRIEF STAGIONE
SYSTEM FOR TRANSFER ABILITY TO
OTHER. FACILITIES THAT ARE
BETTER MAINTAINED TO BE ABLE TO
HANDLE LONG TERM RESIDENTS. AND
SO THANK YOU FOR APPLAUDING THAT
I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
AND HE PAINS IF IT'S OKAY I'D
LIKE TO START WITH YOU WE ARE
DIRECTING THEM AND IF YOU GUYS
CAN OKAY STEVEN HAYNES AND I'D
LIKE TO START WITH YOU IF THAT'S
OKAY. YEAH M. AS A PROBATION
CHIEF AND AS SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN
THE CHIEF ADMINISTRATION OVER
JUVENILE HALL WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON SHIFTING THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ALL YOUNG
PEOPLE IN JUVENILE THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM TO THE COUNTIES.
AND DOES HE- DO YOU THE COUNTIES
HAVE ABILITY TO PROVIDE SERVICE
TO THESE JUVENILES- THESE
JUVENILES- I I'M CONCERNED MY
CONCERN IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TRANSFER THEM ALL TO THE LOCAL
COUNTIES. AND THEY WOULD
NORMALLY BE TAKEN CARE OF IN
SOME CASES BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION SO. A CAN YOU
GIVE ME YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT.
OKAY YES SIR- FOR. YES BIGELOW
NOPE YOU WENT AWAY S. I'M SORRY
THAT CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW YES SIR
MMHM. OKAY YES YES YES.
HARBINSON HERE TO- STEP BACK-
FROM C. FROM A PART HELLO.
HOWEVER I WILL SAY THIS IS THAT
OUR FACILITIES ARE NOT EQUIPPED
JUST LIKE- I JUST TALKED ABOUT
THE FACILITIES AND ON THE ADULT
SIDE OUR FACILITIES IN-
INDIVIDUALS FACE ARE NOT
EQUIPPED TO HOLD YOUNG PEOPLE
FOR- YEARS AT A TIME THE SYSTEMS
WERE NEVER SET UP FOR THAT AND-
WE ARE GOING TO NEED THE STATE
SUPPORT IN ORDER TO GET OUR
FACILITIES TO A POINT IN NOT IN
AND I DON'T TALK ABOUT THIS IN
TERMS OF JUST HAVING SPACE TO BE
ABLE TO HOLD HERE- WHERE YOU
KNOW SO THAT THEY HAVE A SAFE
PLACE TO SLEEP. BUT ALSO. BUT IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE ALSO NEED TO
HAVE THE PROPER PROGRAM FACING
ORDER TO PROVIDE THE PROPER.
THAT THE- YOU NEED TO HAVE AN
ABILITY STEP DOWN. FROM THE FROM
A MORE. SECURE SETTING TO AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
ALLOW THEM TO BE. TO GO OUT INTO
THE COMMUNITY TO BE ABLE TO GO
TO COLLEGE TO BE ABLE TO GET
PART TIME JOBS- TO BE ABLE TO DO
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS IN A WAY
THAT IS REALLY WELL INFORMED BY
TREATMENT PLANT. ALLOWING US TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE THOSE STEPS
ALONG THE WAY. OUR SYSTEM NOW
WE'RE NOT SET UP IN THE IN THE
STATE IS MADE SOMEWHAT OF A
COMMUNITY. IN THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING INVESTIGATE TWENTY THREE
BUT WE ARE A LONG WAY. FROM
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE WHAT I
BELIEVE IS A COMPREHENSIVE NEED
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY- BOTH OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE FROM JJ. INTO OUR
FACILITIES AND THEN BACK OUT
HOME TO THEIR COMMUNITIES- OF
COURSE WE ARE. FARMERS WE'VE
BEEN. THIS WORK FOR A LONG TIME
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL YOU ARE-
KING- BEST PRACTICES WE'VE GOT A
TRACK RECORD OF DOING THIS KIND
OF WORK. FOR THE LAST DECADE NOT
ALL TALK ABOUT FRESNO. BACK WHEN
I RAN MY FACILITY ZERO SEVEN
SEVEN EIGHT YEARS AGO- I HAD
OVER THREE HUNDRED FEET. IN OUR
REGULAR HOME TODAY GOT THIRD OF
THAT TODAY AND IT'S BECAUSE OF
THE GOOD WORK THAT WE CAN JOIN
HERE LOCAL. A 90% OF THE YOUTH
ACROSS THE STATE OUR SERVER
ADVOCACY WE WANT TO TRY TO
REDUCE THAT NUMBER EVEN. MORE
WILL BE. THE RESOURCE- THAT THE
STATE WILL ALLOW FOR THE BURDENS
TO- BE ABLE TO SUCCESSFULLY. TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD BUT OUR WE
READY RIGHT NOW APPS. RIGHT BUT
WE WE'RE GONNA NEED FOR THE-
RESOURCES IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN DO THIS A WAY. THAT
WE SEE IS THE BEST WAY. I YOU
SIR AND I THINK YOU HIGHLIGHTING
WHAT YOU THE- IN FRESNO BECAUSE
I DID I READ I READ A LOT ABOUT
THAT. AND I DO AGREE THAT YOU
WRAPAROUND SERVICES YOU CAN'T
JUST HOUSE THEM- THERE'S GOT TO
BE SOME TYPE OF. EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS GOING TO BE JOB
TRAINING PROGRAMS THERE'S GOT TO
BE SOMETHING. TO GIVE THEM SOME
TYPE OF A- HELLO THERE'S A BIBLE
SCRIPTURE THAT SAYS YOU KNOW A
HOPE AND A FUTURE. RIGHT AND SO-
I DO AGREE WITH THAT AND SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HIGHLIGHTING THAT AND I
APPRECIATE ALL THE YEARS. THAT
YOU'VE INVESTED IN- LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WITH YOUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAREER AND I THINK
IT- THAT IN YOUR HEART AND
PASSION FOR THE YOUTH IN OUR
COMMUNITIES A- AND- AND JUST
YOUR ABILITY TO. AT LEAST PEOPLE
WILL- IS A GREAT THIS IS A GREAT
STEP UP FOR YOU SIR FOR YOU TO
BE APPOINTED THIS POSITION SO
THANK YOU FOR- ACCEPTING IT.
THANK YOU. M. DIRECTOR OF OUR
SKEWS ME CHIEF MILLS I- HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU IF IT'S OKAY.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THE BOARD
SHOULD BE PROVIDED WITH AN
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM. IN WHAT
TYPE OF ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
WOULD YOU SEE LIKE TO SEE IF IT
WERE DEVELOPED OVER THE
FACILITIES. WELL CENTER THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- IT WOULD
OBVIOUSLY BE THE SENATE'S
PREROGATIVE SHOULD THEY WANT TO
GO THAT DIRECTION BUT I THINK IT
NEEDS TO BE THOUGHTFUL AND
PROPERLY RESOURCE- TO ME IT
MIGHT MAKE MORE SENSE THAT IF WE
WERE GOING TO GO THAT DIRECTION
THERE WOULD BE MORE OF AN
INVESTIGATIVE ARM THAT WOULD GO
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
. AND IN THE END REFER THE
INFORMATION TO THEM. BECAUSE
THIS IS SUCH A COMPLEX. AREA OF
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM. THEY'RE
REALLY TAKES PEOPLE WITH DEEP
KNOWLEDGE. TO BE ABLE TO GO AND
REALLY FIND OUT THE FACTUAL IN
THE IN THE ACCURATE INFORMATION.
SO IF WE'RE GOING TO BE I WANNA
MAKE SURE IT'S DOURSON'S STOPS.
I TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S-
THOROUGHNESS. TRANSPARENCY AS
WELL AS- SECONDARY I USED TO
MAKE SURE THAT- IT'S BEING DONE
THE RIGHT WAY. I APPRECIATE THAT
RESPONSE AND THANK YOU AND I
KNOW IT'S IN THE SENATE'S
PURVIEW BUT YOU KNOW I'VE NEVER
BEEN A CHIEF OF POLICE THEM I
DON'T THINK ANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE I KNOWN MY COLLEAGUES TO MY
LEFT IS BEEN. SECRETARY OF
NATURAL RESOURCES. BUDGET MUCH.
I AM SO I WAS JUST INTERESTED IN
YOUR OPINION AND I APPRECIATE
THAT VERY- THAT VERY THOUGHTFUL
RESPONSE THANK YOU SIR AND AGAIN
I'M BOUNCING BACK AND.
CHÁVEZ AYE I DO HAVE A QUESTION-
FOR YOU IF THAT'S OKAY. M. IT
THE OTHER PANEL MEMBERS HAVE AN
EXTENSIVE LAW ENFORCEMENT
BACKGROUND A POLICE CHIEF OF
POLICE OFFICERS PROBATION
OFFICERS A SUCCESS IN THE PARK
VERY MUCH SUCCESS WHICH HE PAINS
IN THE FRESNO COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENT IN THE JUVENILE
PROGRAM JUSTICE FOR THEM THAT
THEY HAVE IN PLACE THERE- A-
BLUE RIBBON EQUITY PANELS
THERE'S JUST A LONG LIST. WITH
WITH FED CHIEF MILLS AND WITH-
BUT- CHIEF PAINS AND SO I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS THAT I AM WITH
THE INFORMATION THAT YOU
SUBMITTED RULES UNLESS IT WASN'T
SOME FULLY AND COMPLETELY
SUBMITTED I YOU'RE A COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS CORRECT OR
FORMER COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. I AM CURRENTLY A
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SANTA CLARA
COUNTY OKAY SO CURRENTLY A
MEMBER I DON'T SEE LAW
ENFORCEMENT BACKGROUND IS IT
MISS ENOUGH THAT THIS
INFORMATION IS SUBMITTED. NO
I'VE NEVER HELD A POSITION ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT. I DON'T SEE
ANYTHING DEALING WITH JUVENILE
JUSTICE OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT IS
THAT MISSING OFF OF THIS
INFORMATION. ROB FIGHT WILL JUST
GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND- AND I APOLOGIZE THAT
IT WASN'T INCLUDED SO I AM BOTH.
AT ESTABLISHED AND CO AT
ESTABLISHED OUR BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON JAIL REFORM IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND WE- CAME UP WITH
SIX HUNDRED RECOMMENDATIONS TO
IMPROVE OUR JAIL WHERE 58%
THROUGH THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS. I
ESTABLISHED- ARE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE TO ADDRESS THEM ALL
AND OUR COMMUNITY. I AM THE CO
CHAIR AND ESTABLISHED HUMAN
TRAFFICKING I COMMISSION AND
ALSO JUST RECENTLY ESTABLISHED
ABOUT A YEAR AGO OUR CHILD
ADVOCACY CENTER COMMUNITY. SO MY
BACKGROUND RELATES TO MY SERVICE
AS AN ELECTED OFFICIAL PLAYING A
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN PUBLIC SAFETY
OF BOTH OF THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND- AS A MEMBER OF
THE STATE AS A CITY COUNCIL I
WORKED. VERY HARD- TO ADDRESS
MEGAN'S LAW SO WE DIDN'T HAVE.
FRANKLY PEOPLE MOVING INTO
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT THE
COMMUNITY KNOWING FOR THIS MOVIE
YEAH- SO MY BACKGROUND IS REALLY
THAT AND THE LIKE TO FISHEL-
PLAYING A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN
PUBLIC SAFETY I SHOULD JUST HAVE
ONE OTHER THING THAT IS OF.
SOMETHING I'M- ABOUT HERE IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY. WE PROCESS- RATE GETS
I THINK FASTER THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTY IN THE COUNTRY. WE DON'T
HAVE A BACKLOG- INCLUDING BEING
ABLE TO DO THAT FOR STRANGERS
UNDER FIVE DAYS. AND WE'RE ABOUT
IT FIFTEEN DAYS FOR ALL OTHER
CATS. THANK YOU I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S THAT'S AND THAT'S A GOOD
A- GOOD THING TO KNOW. I
APPRECIATE THAT VERY MUCH- IN
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME ASK
THOSE QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SENATOR GROWTH. ARMS WELL THIS
IS BEEN A FAIRLY. EXTENSIVE AND
ROBUST. CONVERSATION AMONGST ALL
OF MY COLLEAGUES- AND I THINK A
LOT OF GROUND HAS BEEN COVERED
IDEA. YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF
LOOKING AT THE RESPONSES TO THE
QUESTIONNAIRES- FIRST AND
FOREMOST I THINK I'M I REALLY
NEED TO THANK EACH OF YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE AND YOUR COMMITMENT
BECAUSE- THIS IS NOT EASY WORK
OBVIOUSLY EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE
THAT EACH YOU BRING TO THIS.
THIS BODY OUR TO DO THE WORK.
AND IT HAS BECOME CLEAR TO ME
THROUGH THE CONVERSATION THAT.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE GRAY AREAS
BETWEEN THE INNER SEXUALITY OR
THAT THE INTERCONNECTEDNESS OF
WHAT THE ROLE OF THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IS. AS OF
ONE ONE OF YOU THINK CHIEF MILLS
MAYBE IT WAS YOU MIGHT HAVE BEEN
ACHIEVED. HAYNES MENTIONED AB
ONE OH NINE AND THE- THE WORK
AROUND THAT AND I REMEMBER MY
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERMICRO THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS MEMBER
SAYING TO ME ALONG WITH OUR
SHERIFF AT THAT TIME. YOU KNOW
WE CAN DO THIS BUT YOU NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE RESOURCES-
AND A COUPLE OF YOU'VE MENTIONED
THAT SEVERAL TIMES IN DIFFERENT.
DIFFERENT WAYS FOR DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT REASONS- IN RESPONSE
TO QUESTIONS- WE ALSO KNOW THAT
WE HAVE CERTAINLY NOT ENOUGH
FACILITIES THAT ARE AVAILABLE
FOR. THOSE WHO MIGHT HAVE DRUG
AND ALCOHOL ADDICTIONS. I EAT
FENNEL OBVIOUSLY WE TALKA LOT
ABOUT THAT. TODAY. MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES ALL OF THOSE THINGS- AS
WE TRY TO LOOK AT HOW WE ADDRESS
AND DEAL WITH THOSE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED- AND THE VARIOUS
CATEGORIES OF FOLKS. I'M COMING
BACK BECAUSE- IT WAS FOR THE
QUESTIONS AROUND SAN DIEGO WHEN
WE GOT THE AUDIT REPORT- THAT
REFERENCED MAY BE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR PSEC VERSES-
WHAT A COUNTY SHOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR AND IT'S CLEAR
WE HAVE SOME WORK TO DO IN THIS
AREA. BECAUSE I THINK THE LINES
OF RESPONSIBILITY DELINEATION
WHETHER YOU HAVE ACTUAL
AUTHORITY IN THE ROLE HERE AT
THIS BOARD OF BECAME. A LITTLE
MORE IN CENTER FOCUS IF YOU WILL
WHICH IS WHY YOU GOT THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT SAN DIEGO I KNOW
THERE ARE QUESTIONS ABOUT L. A.
N. AND OTHERS BUT THERE WAS-
QUITE A LONG PERIOD OF TIME AND
EXTENSIVE MEDIA ACCOUNTS OF WHAT
WAS GOING ON IN SAN DIEGO AND
THOSE OF US REPRESENT THE AREA.
MERCEDES BENZ WITH PEOPLE BEFORE
ALL BEFORE THAT AUDIT OCCURRED-
AND SO I THINK THERE'S STILL
WORK TO DO THERE I KNOW IN YOUR
RESPONSES. THIS IS COMING UP FOR
A MEETING IN APRIL- AND I AND I
DO THINK THERE'S BEEN
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT WHETHER AND
THE QUESTION ASK ARE ALSO. I DO
YOU THINK YOU SHOULD HAVE MORE
AUTHORITY WHAT SHOULD IT BE
SHOULD THERE BE ENFORCEMENT I
KNOW CHIEF MILLS YOU GET ASKED
THAT QUESTION AT LEAST TWICE WE
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT- BUT- I THINK
THERE THERE IS GOING TO BE WORK
THAT COMES OUT OF THIS AUDIT.
AND OTHERS THAT MAY- MEAN THAT
THERE WILL BE LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION FOR. THIS BODY TO
TAKE ON MORE OF A ROLE AND I
WOULD JUST. I DON'T HAVE A
QUESTION OF THE RIGHT NOW EXCEPT
MAYBE THAT YOU KEEP AN OPEN MIND
AS YOU HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS.
ARE AT UPCOMING BOARDS BECAUSE
SOMETHING IS NOT WORKING- YOU
KNOW I IT'S HARD TO REPRESENT A
COMMUNITY FOR YOUR JAIL. OF WHO
. YOU KNOW A HUNDRED OVER A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DEATHS. IN A
PERIOD OF TIME- AND THAT SOMEHOW
BETWEEN THE INSPECTIONS. AND THE
ANALYSIS OF TRAINING OF STAFF-
WE SOMEHOW. MISSED AN ABILITY
AND I HAVE TO SAY COLLECTIVELY-
MISSED AN ABILITY TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT TO DO THERE. AND YOU ARE
EXPERTS IN YOUR VARIOUS FIELDS
AND YOU SERVE FOR A PURPOSE AND
THERE ARE GOOD PEOPLE THAT WORK
IN THE JAILS AND THERE ARE GOOD
INTENTIONS BUT SOMETHING DID NOT
GO. WELL AT ALL FOR THIS TO
HAPPEN. AND A PART OF IT IS JAIL
SHOULD NOT BE FACILITIES THAT
ARE. HAVING TO DEAL WITH ALL OF
THE MEDICAL NEEDS BUT SOMEHOW.
IT BECAUSE THEY HAVE BECOME THAT
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
RESOURCES NEED TO BE THERE. TO
PROTECT. THOSE WHO WERE
INCARCERATED- IN TO SUPPORT THE
STAFF THAT WORK THERE SO I'M
JUST GONNA NOT BARRAGED WITH
QUESTIONS BECAUSE I THINK THE
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ASKED BUT
ASK YOU TO KEEP AN OPEN MIND.
AND BE PREPARED TO GIVE US
FEEDBACK ON WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO DO A WHOSE ROLE IS IT.
SHOULD BE A C. C. B. TAPPED
LEGISLATIVELY TO TAKE ON MORE OF
A ROLE TO GIVE YOUR FEEDBACK ON
THAT AND MAYBE NOT JUST SIMPLY
SAY NO WE DON'T SUPPORT THAT OR
GIVE US THE FEEDBACK AND SO I
WOULD JUST ASK A SIMPLE QUESTION
IS OF EACH OF YOU ARE YOU
WILLING TO WORK WITH US TO
RESOLVE SOME OF THESE OBVIOUSLY
GAPS. THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED-
AND HELP US UNDERSTAND WHOSE
ROLE IS IT BECAUSE I BE HONEST
WITH YOU I HAD I HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS THEY FELT
LIKE IT WAS NOT THEIR ROLE- IN
IN MANY IN CERTAIN WAYS I DON'T
WANNA. I DON'T AND YOU TO BE
CAREFUL HOW I SAY THAT BECAUSE
THEY WERE ENGAGED IN A
CONVERSATION BUT- ALSO I THINK
PART OF IT RECOGNIZING THE ROLE
OF AN ELECTED SHERIFF. I WAS A
PIECE OF THAT CONVERSATION SO
SOMEHOW WE'VE GOT TO BRING
THESE. CONVERSATIONS MORE
ALIGNED AND HAVE A DIALOGUE
BETWEEN THE PARTIES TO GET. AT
HOW WE'RE GONNA. HAVE WE'RE
GOING TO DO THIS AND I KNOW
THERE ARE OTHER ISSUES FOR LA.
IN TERMS OF THE FACILITIES AND
NOT JUST A LIE BUT A FEW OTHERS.
BUT WE REALLY NEED TO BE TALKING
MORE ABOUT HOW BEST TO THAT AND
YOU ARE THE EXPERTS- YOU ARE THE
EXPERTS AT THIS WHICH IS WHY
YOU'VE BEEN TAX. TAPPED TO BE ON
THIS. ON THIS BOARD SO- I WOULD
JUST THEN QUICKLY ASK OUR
SUPERVISOR CHÁVEZ. WILL YOU GIVE
SOME REFLECTION ON THIS AND GIVE
SOME THOUGHT IN CASE WE WANT TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU AFTER TODAY
AND ASK. YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW WE
COULD DO THIS BETTER AND MAYBE
AFTER YOU SIT THROUGH THE AUDIT.
FROM SAN DIEGO YOU MIGHT HAVE
MORE TO SHARE WITH WITH MY STAFF
. AMOUNT OF. TIME THAT WOULD BE
AN HONOR TO GET AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THAT WITH YOUR TEAM. I
APPRECIATE THAT CHIEF MILLS- CAN
I ASK THE SAME CONSIDERATION OF
YOU AT THIS POINT. MADAM CHAIR
ABSOLUTELY WOULD BE WILLING TO
BE OPEN MINDED- ASKED AS
PENETRATING QUESTIONS AS WE CAN
I GIVEN THE INFORMATION WE HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO DETERMINE. THE
BEST PATH FORWARD WITH YOUR
STAFF. CHIEF THANK YOU AND CHIEF
PAINS I'M NOT GONNA LEAVE YOU
OUT OF THIS CONVERSATION AND SO
WOULD ASK THE SAME OF YOU.
ABSOLUTELY KNOWLEDGE HERE IF
THERE IS ANYTHING THAT I CAN DO
I AM WILLING TO WORK WITH YOUR
STAFF TO WAS. KNOWN BOTH THROUGH
THE ARTICLE THAT I TO CALL ME TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SOME INPUT- I
KNOW. WE CERTAINLY CAN BE
HELPFUL FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDERS. WHO WE ARE WITH.
THANK EACH OF YOU AND TO THE
CHIEFS AND THE SUPERVISOR- I
HAVE THE BOARD LIST HERE SO
DON'T WORRY WE WON'T JUST PUT
YOU ON THE SPOT BECAUSE YOU'RE
UP FOR REAPPOINTMENT-
APPOINTMENT CONFIRMATIONS. WE
WILL BE CHECKING IN WITH A
NUMBER OF THESE OTHER BOARD
MEMBERS AS WELL SO I. APPRECIATE
THAT AND- GIVEN YOUR PATIENCE I
REALLY WANT TO SAY THANK YOU AND
I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO MAY
WISH TO SPEAK. AND WE'RE GONNA
START IN SUPPORT AND I SEE
SOMEONE ALREADY APPROACH IN THE
DIET SO LET ME SAY WELCOME TO
YOU. YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION THAT
YOU REPRESENT AND YOUR COMMENTS.
GREAT THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM
AND MEMBERS A GOOD AFTERNOON
DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CHEAP PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA WHAT DO IT KNOWLEDGE-
ALL OF THE IMPORTANT WORK OF
THE- GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES IN
THE PANEL HERE TODAY FOR THE
BOARD OF STATE COMMUNITY.
CORRECTIONS I WOULD LIKE TO
OFFER SOME SPECIFIC COMMENTS-
REGARDING THE APPOINTMENT OF A
CHIEF KERR KANE- TO THE BOARDOF
STATE COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS AS
AS A KEY LEADER AND- MEMBER OF
OUR ORGANIZATION. AND REALLY
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR-
CHEAP HAYNES'S APPOINTMENT. AS I
THINK BOTH THE CHIEF SHARED AND
I THINK WAS- THE ANSWER. TO THAT
QUESTION. THE CHIEF AS A VERY
STRONG. ON EVIDENCE BASED
PRACTICES- THE IMPORTANCE OF
TRAINING AND BUILDING
COLLABORATION- LOOKING BOTH
UPSTREAM AND HOW WE CAN CONTINUE
TO KEEP. INDIVIDUALS FROM COMING
INTO CONTACT WITH THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM BUT ALL ALSO HOW WE
CREATE. AND SAFE AND HEALTHY AND
SUSTAINABLE PATHWAYS OUT OF THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM BOTH FOR ADULTS
AND JUVENILES. AND I THINK
IMPORTANTLY MAKING SURE THAT THE
- CONVERSATION CONTINUES TO
FOCUS ON. THE IMPORTANCE OF BOTH
COMMUNITY SAFETY AND EQUITY- I
THINK AS WAS REFLECTED- THE
CHIEF- IMPORTANTLY YOU KNOW
CARES VERY DEEPLY ABOUT. THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE SERVED- IN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND WORK AT THE
SEC SO- ON BEHALF OF THE
CHIEFTAINCY PARK WANT TO- EXTEND
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
APPOINTMENT CHIEF PAINS TO THE-
SEC AND AGAIN. I THINK ALL OF
THE- APPOINTEES HERE TO. SEE THE
TIME THANK YOU. SO MUCH AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN
HANGING IN THERE WITH US- SEEING
NO ONE ELSE APPROACH THE DIS
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED-
LET ME WELCOME BACK OUR
MDERATOR AND SAY THANK YOU FOR
HANGING IN THERE WITH US AND ASK
IF YOU WANT TO TEE UP PEOPLE WHO
WISH TO SPEAK. AND I GUESS I
SHOULD GIVE THAT NUMBER AGAIN
IT'S BEEN A WHILE- OUR TOLL FREE
NUMBER. FOR THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO
TWO SIX. EIGHT ONE SIX THREE.
THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN SIX TWO
TWO FOUR SIX TWO. MISTER
MODERATOR. THANK YOU AND WELCOME
BACK. THANK VERY MUCH WE WOULD
LIKE FIRST SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
NOBODY IS GEARING UP. THANK YOU
ARE MISTER MODERATOR WILL BE
BACK IN JUST A MOMENT LET ME SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THAT WISHES TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO ANY OF THE
CONFEREES. SEEING NO ONE
APPROACH IN THE DYESS MISTER
MODERATOR I'M COMING BACK TO YOU
TO TEAR PEOPLE WHO MAY WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FILED BY
ZERO. AND NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
OUT OF HERE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR HELP TODAY MR MODERATOR
WE SO APPRECIATED- HAVEN'T GIVEN
THE OPPORTUNITY AND HEARD FROM
THOSE IN SUPPORT AND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THOSE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION I'M GOING TO BRING
IT BACK. TO OUR THE COLLEAGUES
AND I THINK WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND DO. IS EACH OF
THESE ARE APPOINT TWO SEPARATELY
ARE. IF I COULD SO. LET ME ASK
FOR A MOTION IN SUPPORT OF
CYNTHIA SUPERVISOR CYNTHIA M.
TRAVIS AS A- MEMBER OF THE BOARD
OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS. CENTER LAYERED
THANK YOU- THAT MOTION IS NOW ON
THE TABLE MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROOVE
KAMLAGER HI KAMLAGER I LAYERED
HI THERE I BATES. BATES OBSCENE
ATKINS FIVE ATKINS SORRY ON CALL
THAT IS A FIT- THREE IN SUPPORT
ONE OF STAINED BUT IT WILL BE ON
CALL SUPERVISOR- TRAVIS THAT
WILL BE ENOUGH VOTES IN TERMS TO
IN TERMS OF MOVING THIS TO THIS
FULL SENATE FOR CONFIRMATION
CONGRATULATIONS AND IT WILL
STILL BE ON CALL- SUPERVISOR
KIRK HAINES OF MEMBER BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
OF MOTION. MOVING UP MADAM VICE
CHAIR HAS MADE TE MOTION MADAM
SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. GROOVE KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER
I LAYERED HI THERE I BATES. AYE
BATES AYE ATKINS AYE ATKINS FIVE
ZERO THAT IS FOR- VOTES IN
SUPPORT AND IT WILL BE ON CALL
FOR SENATOR GROWTH WHEN SHE
COMES BACK THAT IS ALSO ANOTHER
VOTES TO MOVE THIS TO THE SENATE
FOR FULL CONFIRMATION SO. I
CONGRATULATIONS AND AGAIN IT
WILL BE ON CALL- FOR THE RETURN
OF CENTER GROVE- S. I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION OF SUPPORT
FOR CHIEF ANDREW G. MILLS MEMBER
BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS I WOULD SO MOVE
SENATOR LAYERED HAS MADE THE
MOTION MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. GROVE
KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER I THERE'D HI
THERE I BATES HI. I CAN FIVE
INSIDE WHAT IS YOUR OWN THANK
YOU THAT IS ALSO UP FOR VOTES IN
SUPPORT- WE WILL KEEP THIS OPEN
FOR. OUR ON ON CALL FOR SENATOR
GROWTH YOU HAVE ENOUGH- TO MOVE
FORWARD TO THE FULL SENATE FOR
CONFIRMATION SO LET ME SAY
CONGRATULATIONS TO EACH OF YOU.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
TODAY CHAIRMAN ATKINS YES MADAM
VICE CHAIR. QUESTION ON ON. THE
FLOOR SUPERVISOR CHÁVEZ MINE IS
THE TEMPORARY ABSTENTION I JUST
HAVE TO GET ONE A SPECIFIC ITEM
CLARIFIED REGARDING ON HER
POSITION AS A CANDIDATE. AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IN TERMS
OF HER ABILITIES AND HER
BACKGROUND INTO RESPONSE TO THE
QUESTIONS THEY WERE OUTSTANDING
BUT I DO NEED TO CHECK ON THAT
PARTICULAR THING BECAUSE
ACTUALLY AFFECTED ME I WAS THE
OF TO THAT ONE POINT TIME
BECAUSE I WAS A CANDIDATE FOR A
- BUT YOU. CHEN SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S NOT A
PROBLEM NOW AND YOU KNOW AND I
CAN RESOLVE THAT WHEN WE GET TO
THE FLOOR THANK YOU MATT HER TO
THINK I DIDN'T THINK SHE DID A
GREAT JOB BECAUSE SHE DID NOT A
VICE FOR THANK YOU FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION SO NOTED AND
SUPERVISOR CHÁVEZ AYE AYE I AM
SURE YOU HEARD THOSE CAUGHT
TOMORROW VICE CHAIR THE SO THAT
IS NOTED. AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU AGAIN- CONGRATULATIONS TO
EACH OF YOU AND I WILL STAY HERE
AND WAIT SENATOR GROWTH TO COME
BACK AND AN ADD ON BUT YOU ARE
FREE TO GO I HAVE OF THE REST OF
YOUR AFTERNOON THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OFF. SO LET ME ASK STAFF TO
BE SURE AND MAKE A CALL TO
SENATOR GROW SO SHE CAN COME
BACK AND ADD ON BUT WITH THAT-
THIS DOES CONCLUDE TODAY'S
AGENDA I DO WANT TO THANK. ALL
OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY. IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING. TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
YOU CAN VISIT OUR WEBSITE FOR
INSTRUCTIONS. YOUR COMMENTS AND
YOUR SUGGESTIONS ARE TRULY
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD SO. LET
ME THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION- YOUR
COOPERATION TODAY- YOU ARE FREE
TO EXIT AND I WILL STAY HERE AND
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN WITH OUR
SECRETARY. THANK YOU THAT WAS I
WAS JUST. TO YEAH RIGHT YEAH SHE
IS VERY. OKAY.
FULL ON ITEM ONE SEE CYNTHIA
CHAVEZ GROOVE RIGHT ROOF I OF
ONE D. R. CHIEF KIRK HAINES
GROVE HI GROUP I. ITEM ONE E.
CHIEF ANDREW MILLS GROOVE GROVE
NO. LIKE MY SAN DIEGO WAS.
REALLY YEAH I STARTED THERE.
I'M THANK YOU HI EVERYONE WE ARE
NOW ADJOURNED.